Wohin gehst du denn?
Monka W.
Easy.
Easy as f**k!
Und ihr werdet nicht glauben, was aktuell der Top 1 Trend auf Pornhub ist, dreimal dürft
mir raten da kommt ihr nie drauf was sollte es anders sein
rein rhetorische frage ich warte nicht erwarte nicht dass ihr das wisst aber
was ist es es ist auf erwart zwei wenn es jetzt auch alles da sein können
alles das das war eigentlich klar oder also ich meine was sollte es sonst
anderes sein
es ist eigentlich nicht möglich dass ist das du kannst theoretisch das schon
predicten ich wusste auch in instant als valorant rausgekommen ist dass das top top
search term ist ist halt einfach so die leute gucken immer nach dem gleichen kram es ist sehr
predictable alles ja ist klar woher weißt du weil ich nachgeguckt habe weil ich nachgeguckt habe
weil ich mir nahezu sicher war es ist overwatch 2 und ich hab nachher und es ist overwatch 2 gewesen
Leute ja ich muss mal
Zeig mal im stream lul alter wenn ich gebannt werden will muss mal kurz vm updaten
Homesystem ab ein bisschen updaten in der zeit ein bisschen sind natürlich for science für was sonst
Was haben wir denn hier?
Kekkeltest haben wir da.
Es ist ja schön, dass ich meine Sachen so schön benenne.
Kekkeltest, mann, was...
Warum, jetzt bei erster, warum
benenne ich die Dinger so dumm? Ich hab doch keine Ahnung
mehr heute, was eigentlich Kekkeltest
genau gewesen ist. Noch schlimmer!
Wisst ihr was noch schlimmer ist?
Ich hab letztens...
Also, was heißt letztens?
Vorgest...ne, wann war ich auf der Arbeit?
War sogar gestern.
Äh, nee.
Ist doch egal.
Dienstag.
Am Mittwoch.
Ich jetzt weiß, ich hab mich alle Tage durchgekackt, Alter.
Mittwoch war ich in Frankfurt auf der Arbeit, war im Collège Mittagessen und die waren,
bei Mittagessen, wir waren mal Mexikaner, die waren ultra langsam in der Bedienung.
So hast du gefühlt, die bedienen so in Zeitlupe.
Da hab ich tatsächlich, es ist mir so rausgerutscht, da hab ich wahrscheinlich irgendwie alle
verwirrt die dabei, weil die haben gesagt, der Max redet wieder ein wirres Zeug.
Da hab ich gesagt, lul alter, was ist denn das? Kekkel. Richtig dumm, Alter. Die haben einfach
gesagt, hä, was labert er wieder für ein Zeug, mann? Es ist niemand, es ist niemand
drauf eingegangen. Es ist niemand drauf eingegangen. Die haben das noch nicht mal, noch nicht mal
irgendwie anhand irgendwie der Mimik zu erkennen gewesen, dass es zur Kenntnis genommen wurde.
Da haben sich einfach alle gesagt, hä, was ist wieder mit dem los, egal, gehen wir gar nicht erst mal drauf ein, Alter.
Nobby ist ohne Emote, kennt das, Alter.
Lol, Alter, was ist das?
Und als wäre es das noch nicht gewesen, dass ich sage, lul, Alter, was ist das, kann man doch verstehen.
Und dann sag ich noch, für mich so hinten drauf, keckel, Alter.
Hahaha.
Meine Güte, Twitch Emotes ist einfach, das ist zu, vor allem wenn man sich da monatelang
hier über, da strebt und sich daran gewöhnt ist, dein Hirn verbindet sich, bildet irgendwie
neue Synapsen und Verbindungen, dass du automatisch in Emotes sprichst.
Nee, die haben nicht gepennt, die waren einfach nur langsam, das war kurz vor 12, das ist
normalerweise richtig hochbetrieb da die gehen die ganzen leute in frankfurt
furtern leute aber moment was das verpackung wollte ich sagen leute ich
muss montag presentation halten in frankfurt über ein thema wisst ihr was
das blöde ist und fuhden fuhden muss ich auf jeden fall auch aber da bin ich
nicht in frankfurt am montag ich mache das remote aber aber fuhden werde ich
auf jeden fall auch am montag ich muss eine presentation halten und zwar ich war
so bescheuert ich habe selbst gesagt dass ich das machen will und ich dachte
mir das ist bestimmt ganz nice wenn man da was drüber erzählen kann aber jetzt wo
das ist und wo ich dann quasi auch präsentation vorbereiten muss und so
hatte ich überhaupt keinen bock mehr drauf an sich das eigentliche
präsentieren mache ich tatsächlich mittlerweile ganz gern aber das
vorbereiten von irgendwelchen folien überlegen welche reihenfolge sagst du
was wie sagst du dass dass sie das verstehen wer sitzten da eigentlich da
können die das überhaupt verstehen machst du das zuerst oder jenes zu
erster dass immer powerpoint ist absolut abfakt ich weiß nicht wer bei
microsoft der meinung ist das powerpoint als schönes schönes user interface hat
beziehungsweise irgendwie schön zu bedienen ist ich weiß ja nicht also
meine persönliche lieblings präsentations folien die kann man nicht
Material ist eigentlich Markdown zu PDF exportiert und fertig. Einfach paar Seiten in Markdown,
PDF exportieren, fertig. Das kann ich bei uns auf der Arbeit aber nicht machen,
weil die alle darauf stehen, dass wir die Corporate Identity gestylte Vorlage verwenden.
Nee, nee, Beamer brauchen wir nicht. Oder meinst du die Software heißt Beamer? Nee,
beamer beamer brauchen wir nicht am liebsten schreibe ich irgendwie 3 4 seiten markdown oder
gut in dem fall wenn es jetzt 14 seiten markdown pdf export bamm drauf fertig aber die ist da nicht
corporate identity mit dem logo und in der richtigen farbe und ja die vorlagen sind richtig
frickelig ich mache ja von der vorlage ich verwende ja von der vorlage kaum was ich verwende von der
vorlage das titelblatt weil da stehen sie besonders drauf dass das eben im corporate style ist
und die anderen sachen die habe ich dann immer mit irgendwelchen ich mache ja keine twitch
emotes rein in die präsentation des check da keine aber ich mache manchmal emojis rein
ich glaube das kapieren die leute dann schon eher ach ja gerade dabei sind ich muss mal kurz
updaten hier alles bevor wir anfangen es gab nämlich ein paar was will das von
mir ruby test unit will be installed before it's ruby dependency dependency
cycle detected warum habe ich überhaupt noch mal ruby installiert ruby wo
weshalb warum anscheinend ist das ich versuche mal ruby zu
zu deinstallieren, was dann passiert.
Ach, Lolcat braucht das, ja, das ist natürlich wichtig.
Also, Lolcat ist ja prinzipiell das zweitwichtigste Programm nach C-Matrix.
Das können wir nicht einfach deinstallieren, das geht nicht.
das war mal upgraden und wenn wir gerade dabei sind lassen wir den home assistant hier auch
noch mal upgraden dass wir nämlich aktuellsten versionen haben bevor wir dann anfangen können
das die richtige ip ey wahnsinn og ich habe sogar das plugin hier drinne um nicht zu sagen
sagen Pogu uninstall ja das brauchen wir nicht jetzt installieren wir gleich von github neu was
wir heute machen sage ich gleich sage ich gleich mache erst mal updates wir bauen ein paar neue
funktionen ein in mein home assistant addon können auch gleich gucken ob die github actions
funktionieren zum bauen des images ip league monka ist jetzt ist vorbei leute ip league
seid ihr schon drin chat schon schon eingeloggt ja ich weiß ich weiß bei euch geht es immer schnell
So wir müssen mal kurz Home Assistant Update machen, erstmal Home Assistant Core und dann
OS.
In der Zwischenzeit mach ich Betriebssystem Update, dann mach ich noch die andere Packages
Update.
Ja und dann erzähl ich euch was wir heute machen, wie gesagt wir bauen heute an meinem
Home Assistant weiter, äh nicht an meinem Home Assistant weiter, an meinem Home Assistant
addon, addon, ich kann nicht mehr reden, an meinem Home Assistant addon bauen wir weiter,
dem hier denn es gibt ein paar tatsächlich interessante feature requests dafür das erste
ist das kann man leider nicht umsetzen aber das erste ist das fände ich gut wenn das
wenn das möglich ist das heißt wir müssen vielleicht noch mal irgendwann das fiat android
apk de-compile falls man sowas on stream machen darf ich glaube eher nicht und gucken
ob da nicht doch eine funktion drinne ist also der schreibt hier er würde gerne automatisch
das Aufladen des Elektroautos beenden, wenn die Batterie auf 80% ist.
So und das geht nicht, weil, und jetzt kommt der Hit, Fiat gedacht hat, diese Funktion
braucht man nicht.
Also du kannst über die Fiat API bzw. auch über die offizielle Fiat App, kannst du
das Chargen starten, also du kannst zum Beispiel einschalten, also du steckst das Ladegerät
ans Auto und du kannst das dann zeitgesteuert starten.
das funktioniert
vielleicht ist das ja ein Trick
dass man es time gesteuert ausschaltet
dann kannst du sagen morgens um 8 solltest du anfangen zu laden oder nachts um 2
solltest du anfangen zu laden
falls du künstigen Stromtarif hast, das geht
es gibt auch einen Knopf in der App
Start Charging Now
was es nicht gibt ist
und ich habe keine Ahnung
warum Fiat einen Knopf einbaut
Start Charging Now
aber nicht
Stop charging now
Das gibt es nicht
Vier hat einfach gedacht nope das wollen wir nicht doch doch ich kann die wallbox ausschalten wenn irgendjemand eine remote steuerbare
ladegerät hat
geht das
Es max es gibt es gibt keine funktion das
Charging auszuschalten. Das haben die nicht eingebaut.
Du kannst Charging nur starten, du kannst Charging nicht stoppen.
Das ist ja das Problem. Du kannst sagen Charge Now, du kannst aber nicht sagen
Stop Charging Now. Die checken es halt nicht.
Du kannst prinzipiell automatisches Charging ausschalten und dann
zeitbasiert einschalten. Das ist vielleicht noch eine... Nein, das willst du
wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich machen und vielleicht vielleicht gibt es die
möglichkeit dass irgendwie zeitgescheuert mit trick 17 zu machen das
müsste ich das müsste ich mal ausprobieren ob das ob das funktioniert
ja kann man es auch über mit dem zeitgeschwind vielleicht vielleicht
das probiere ich tatsächlich mal das muss ich tatsächlich mal probieren dann
ja also das ist das ist die erste das ist die erste anfrage die ich gekriegt
habe habe ich ihm gesagt das geht gar nicht wirklich ich habe übrigens hier unten noch
mal die automatisierung dran gehängt und ihm gezeigt wie ich das aktuell mache weil ich
habe ja eine wallbox ich habe ein ladegerät wo du per api drauf zugreifen kannst also ich
habe beispielsweise zwei automatisierungen nämlich die erste ist alle 15 minuten gucken ob der
charger noch ja leistung braucht über halb von 50 watt das heißt im prinzip ist das ein check
ob der noch lädt
fehler in allen teilen behalten ja also die die haben komische die haben komische funktionen in
ihre app drinne beziehungsweise in ihrer api drinne die haben zum beispiel drinne dass man wie gesagt
laden starten kann aber laden nicht stoppen kann und jetzt kommt die haben auch drinne das ist auch
so idiotisch gemacht ich weiß nicht warum das ist aber das kann ich theoretisch umgehen die haben
auch die funktion in der app dass man klimaanlage einschalten kann also zum beispiel oder was heißt
nicht klimaanlage man kann generell preconditioning einschalten also sprich heizen oder kühlen falls
mal gleich losfahren will, aber man kann Preconditioning nicht ausschalten, also sprich, wenn ich jetzt
sage, ah, ich fahre in 5 Minuten los, ich mach jetzt schonmal warm und dann kriege ich
einen Anruf, keine Ahnung, was auch immer, ich muss heute nicht los, da kann ich nicht
wieder ausschalten, da muss ich raus ins Auto gehen um die Heizung auszuschalten, richtig
hängen geblieben. Da habe ich aber was gefunden in der App, intern gibt es diese API wohl,
man sagen kann Precondition On und Precondition Off. In der offiziellen App gibt es nur Precondition
On. Aber ich weiß halt nicht, ob das irgendwelche Nachteile hat, diesen Request an Autos zu
schicken, in denen das in der offiziellen App nicht angeboten wird. Deswegen ist das
in meinem Addon auch, ähm, ich zeig das mal kurz, deswegen ist das in meinem Addon auch
Dangerous weil man weiß ja nicht was passiert
Ja so und wie gesagt ich habe ich habe zwei zwei automations für mein
Auto beziehungsweise für das ladegerät der guckt alle 15 minuten nach ob es noch lädt also sprich ob es einfach mehr als 50
war leistung braucht wenn das der fall ist dann macht er einen deep refresh deep refresh ist
fiat sprache für batteriestatus updaten warum es nicht einfach update battery level oder status
heißt keine ahnung fiat war der meinung deep refresh ist ein guter name für batteriestatus
update kommt man ja auch sofort darauf dass damit die batterie gemeint ist wenn man die
prefresh liest cringe wenn er nicht drauf kommt so also sprich alle 15 minuten aktualisiert er
bei mir den Batteriestand, solange der Charger eben lädt und wenn er fertig laden ist, also
wenn der CarState auf Completed wechselt für mehr als 5 Sekunden, also das habe ich eingestellt
mit mehr als 5 Sekunden, nicht dass der beispielsweise irgendwie ein bisschen wackelt, sowas weiß
ich, 99, 100, 100, 99, 99, 99, 100, 100 und dann bleibt er auf 100, für den Fall der
fälle dass er irgendwie da problem hat also wenn die wenn das auto fertig geladen hat
also wenn der charging state auf completed geht für mehr als fünf sekunden dann macht
er einen deep refresh also er ruft noch einmal den batteriestatus ab dann wartet er 30 sekunden
für den fall der fälle dass die api lahmarschisch ist und dann schickt er mir eine notification
an mein Smartphone wo drinne steht Auto fertig geladen hat 5,5 Stunden gedauert oder so was
ja steht da, da steht dann 5,7,8,9 Stunden dann weiß ich kann den Stecker abziehen oder
zumindest das das Auto 100% ist also das ist zum Beispiel ne Anfrage die finde ich die
würde ich gerne einbauen geht aber nicht weil es die API nicht her gibt so ohne weiteres
So, und dann haben wir eine Anfrage, die bauen wir heute ein, sofern das möglich ist, aber
müsste eigentlich relativ easy sein.
Aber noch eine andere Anfrage, nämlich ob wir nicht, Kokona, Freedom Units, ob wir nicht
die Kilometer die das ausgibt nicht in miles konvertieren können und da dachte ich mir
dass das eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee ist sowas einzubauen.
Es geht natürlich nicht über die offizielle api, die offizielle api ist ja könnte auch
aus england sein tatsächlich, aber man kann es auf der offiziellen api nicht abfragen.
Ich habe die Vermutung, entweder hängt das am Standort des Autos fest, in was für einer
Einheit der das zurückgibt, wo das Auto zugelassen ist wahrscheinlich, oder in welchem Land der
Account erstellt wurde, oder aber sie geben alles in Kilometer aus und sie rechnen es
kleinseitig in der app um also ich habe versucht aus der fiat api miles raus zu
bekommen in dem ich beispielsweise die den standort umgestellt habe auf us
also lokal local umgestellt habe auf en us also sowas hier en us
standardmäßig ist es dde und ich habe es umgestellt bringt nichts es kommt
trotzdem weiter in kilometer zurück deswegen werden wir das ganze
kleinseitig machen ich werde einfach gucken wo gibt es kilometer units und die werden dann in mails umgewandelt
Schauen wir mal
Wir sind nicht gleich mit jahrt weil das in mails haben will ich weiß ich jahrt ist quasi so das amy fußballfeld oder
die amy fußballfeld einheit
Also die beste die beste einheit ist immer noch wenn man mäuse sich auf amazon anguckt irgendwie 52
ounces schwer da habe ich absolut keine ahnung meils kann ich so ungefähr also ich denke mir
immer meils ist quasi die hälfte also von kilometer in meils ist ungefähr die hälfte
oder ungefähr ein Drittel weg, ein Drittel ist es ungefähr, ungefähr ein Drittel weg,
dann bist du ungefähr bei Miles und ich weiß, dass es nicht genau stimmt, aber so ungefähr,
ja und ja umgedreht ungefähr 30% drauf, also wenn du quasi einmal die Hälfte drauf
hast und einmal die Hälfte, dann hast du ungefähr über den Daumen gepeilt so, aber
ja, das müssen wir dann ein bisschen genauer umrechnen.
Ne, das ist jetzt nicht umgedreht.
Ist es nicht umgedreht?
Ja, doch, wollte ich gerade sagen.
So, Updates sind durch, dann Restarten wir mal kurz, mal kurz mal schauen ob es noch
Colonel Updates gibt oder sowas, wir sind immer noch im LTS Colonel, alles gut, so lass
mal kurz überlegen, haben wir alles geupdatet, das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht, finde
ich gut, Harry Poggers. Twitch, Twitch Emotes, FTW, so, Keckel. Jetzt mal neu starten und
dann können wir anfangen. Also das probieren wir heute mal einzubauen, allerdings müssen
wir vorher noch ein paar Sachen einbauen, dass ich das besser, das besser handeln kann
in Zukunft, nämlich, ich, wir faken mal die Fiat API, weil ich kann ihr mein echtes Passwort
und das, und die E-Mail und so natürlich im Stream nicht eintippen und dazu kommt, dass
es auch blöd ist immer Anfragen zu stellen, ich werd einfach irgendeine Fake API machen
bei mir, die halt was antwortet, was so aussieht wie von der Fiat API.
Mockchamp
Ne wir machen kein Mock Server wir machen das viel billiger
Ich mach nen fiat client der einfach nur fake daten zurück gibt wir machen gar keine requests
Mockchamp genau max könnte mal deine hilfe brauchen dann schieß los
Wie packe ich mein go back in ein virtual host für ein ss
Moment jetzt muss ich mal unbedingt mit virtual host meinst du du meinst keine vm du meinst
du was wie beim apache oder beim engine x dass das dann quasi auf einer ip mehrere domains gibt
oder ja gehe ich jetzt gehe ich jetzt mal vor aus das ist apache muss es denn apache sein wirklich
also wenn ich die auswahl habe zwischen irgendwas und apache dann nämlich irgendwas
Es muss Apechi sein, dann weiß ich es aus dem Kopf nicht, Apechi-Config ist Massive-Pains-Champ.
Keine Ahnung aus dem Kopf.
Die allerallereinfachste Variante wäre ein Kaddi davor, da musst du nämlich gar nichts
machen.
Der macht alles für dich.
Du musst quasi auf der Kommandozeile drei Befehle eintragen und dann gehts einfach.
Aber ok, also wenn es in Apache sein muss, dann weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht.
Ja, irgendwie so, ganz ehrlich Apache-Config muss ich so selten machen und meistens drücke
ich mich da vor, wenn das ansteht, dann lasse ich das irgendjemand anderes machen.
Du kannst übrigens immer Apache mit SSL eh nicht so viel anfangen, weil du brauchst
wahrscheinlich in Let's Encrypt Zertifikate, d.h. du brauchst noch nebenbei ein Thirdbot
oder in irgendeinen Client für Let's Encrypt, also du brauchst wahrscheinlich ein Thirdbot,
der das Zertifikat für dich abruft, ein Renew Job, der dann Zertifikate renewed und
den apache reloadet zertifikate hast du dann dann ist wirklich bloß die apache
konfig aber das kann ich dir aus dem kopf nicht sagen keine ahnung
i don't know
es gibt doch aber bestimmt einen
Das ist der google einfach einfach google von 2012 keck alter proxy pass proxy pass
reverse und leute apache config ist für mich ein buch mit sieben sieben siegel hier sowas
ich habs ich habs noch nie gecheckt ich muss sagen engine x config ist jetzt nicht so viel
besser, aber schon ein bisschen besser. Und Kaddi-Config ist finde ich mit Abstand das
beste. Also da kannst du nichts sagen. Kaddi-Config ist wirklich nice, viel einfacher gehts nicht,
zumal du nicht mal ein Konfig brauchst, sondern einfach Befehle angeben kannst. Dann sagst
du einfach Kaddi-Reverse-Proxy-From-To, fertig aus. Du brauchst nur eine Konfig-Datei wenn
nur DNS-Challenge für letzter Encrypt machen willst, aber ansonsten brauchst du die nicht.
Traffic-Config ist abartig, fast so eklig wie Apache. Dafür hat er mir eingebaut. Hat mal
jemand Traffic-Config von Hand gemacht? Das ist wirklich abartig, Leute. Guckt euch das mal an.
mit docker ist es easy, aber du kannst ja auch config von hand machen, das sieht dann ungefähr
so aus ja
sieht jetzt nicht schlimm aus, aber insgesamt ist es mega umständlich
Ja da hast du komplett gelitten. Du kommst halt manchmal nicht drumherum. Zum Beispiel
wenn du sag mal du willst irgendwas vor deinen Home Assistant stellen. So du willst halt
irgendwas was easy ist mit eingebautem DNS-Challenge und ohne irgendwelche extra Wurst. Dann ist es
ich bin mit traffic gar nicht so verkehrt die haben so gut wie alles eingebaut poste braucht für let's
Encrypt inklusive alle möglichen dns challenge provider
Wofür yaml ist yaml ist ein format für config das ist so quasi was wie inny bloß mit einrückungen
yaml ist eigentlich ein jason superset
so warte mal super super set heißt es kann alles was jason kann also jedes gültige jason
ist gültiges jammel aber nicht jedes gültige jammel ist gültiges jason so rum jammel sieht
zwar komplett anders aus wie jason aber jammel ist ein super set von jason glaubt man gar
nicht ist aber so ja also kann es wirklich ist jason auch in einem jammel datei in jammel
datei schreiben warum weshalb man auf die idee gekommen ist ich weiß es nicht aber
Aber, ja, Leute, ich glaube, bevor wir richtig anfangen, ich hab ein Problem, muss mal ganz
kurz nochmal, ich war nämlich vor einer Stunde was futtern und mittlerweile ist es anscheinend
durch.
Ich muss mal ganz schnell aufs Klo, wir fangen in 5 Minuten dann richtig an, muss mal kurz
kacken.
Stream an die Kackengelden, die Ludel!
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
So wieder da
Das ist ein life goal fürs kacken bezahlt werden
Ich ich ich wurde ja nicht fürs kacken bezahlt das hat ja keiner primes habt
Kann ich auch nicht so muss ich jetzt auch kein schlechtes gemissen haben oder so
Wird von homos ist so blöds klingt das nicht aber ich habe meine vage in homos ist denn
ich habe quasi einen graf wie dick ich bin beziehungsweise wie wie sehr es runter geht
oder nicht denn jetzt dankeschön für den zapp rock md kacke verklickt die abo falle
schlägt jetzt zu nico rock dankeschön massive subscriptions leute
mein klo ist leider ein ticken zu alt ich krieg da keine gedatengescheit abgegriffen
hätte ich hätte ich was bisschen neueres aber gut ich meine ist mein
klo hat eine serielle steht schnell aber ich habe nichts gefunden irgendwie wie
man da was auslesen kann barcode dankeschön für den sub
hast du pro
leute was haltet von einem recipe bei peer wozu
Nö, braucht man nicht, finde ich unsinnig.
Das ist doch die Tastatur, oder? Das ist doch die
Raspberry Pi in Tastaturform.
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander? Ja.
Nee, ist komplett useless, ich hab keine Ahnung wofür das da ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Serielle Shitstelle.
Ja, man könnte ja da vielleicht was sinnvolles drüber abfragen,
aber ich weiß nicht, weiß nicht was.
Brauche mich auch nicht da was anzuschließen. So.
wir haben rebooted ja da legen wir mal los also repos, ich ach wir haben das noch nie
geklont oder was? Moment habe ich hier überhaupt die keys dass ich das dass ich
hier was pushen kann? Mein Klon kann auf GitHub jeder. Hab ich die Keys hier überhaupt? So,
Wunderbar
Okay, so können wir anfangen also wir haben alles geupdatet
Ne homos ist den haben wir nicht geupdatet
Ja homos ist aber nicht geupdatet, müssen wir auch noch machen hier install
Asphalt als was arbeitet ihr also ich arbeite wobei ich wenn du es genau wissen
willst kannst du einfach diese zwei Videos angucken müssen wir das gleiche erzählen
level 2 booster guck mal das gem train hat neue eigens mittlerweile
Alter ich blicke bei Twitch nicht mehr durch, es geht mir auch sonstwo vorbei.
Ich habe heute Morgen irgendeine Anzeige bekommen auf Twitch, ich kann jetzt irgendwelche Leute
hosten und Leute inviteen über einen Browser und sonst was denke ich mir, aber Alter wen
soll ich denn inviteen?
Hat das jetzt funktioniert, hat das jetzt geupdatet?
Also wir fangen mit folgender Sache an, also das ist das Feature, den wir uns heute widmen
werden.
Mal gucken, ob wir dort Konvertierungen einbauen können von Kilometer zu Meilen.
Wir müssen aber vorher noch was anderes machen, und zwar...
Wir müssen später testen, ob das Bild funktioniert, das automatische Bild über GitHub, das gucken wir dann.
Ist mein Home Assistant Supervised? Ja.
Nee.
Es ist Home Assistant OS in der VM, ja, das ist mit Supervised, aber das ist nicht...
Das ist nicht die Supervised-Installation, weil...
Da geht laufen irgendwas kaputt, oder es laufen was, was ich nicht supporte und...
Was auch immer.
Ich hab einfach eine extra VM, ein gutes, fertig.
Und jetzt zum testen habe ich natürlich auch eine extra vm die brauche ich aber brauche ich aber nur hier im stream sieht man ja ist da ist ja im prinzip nix drin
außer außer cute hs am start
Der rest ist das ist fake
Also das erste was wir jetzt mal machen müssen ist folgendes
Ich will ja hier im stream nicht mein passport eingeben
Warum habe ich da BigBugBunny laufen? Wo kommt das her?
Wo kommt die Kamera her, was habe ich denn hier mal eingebaut?
Und warum habe ich das da eingebaut?
Ich weiß es beim besten Willen nicht mehr.
Können wir das nicht einfach mal disablen?
Was brauchen tun wir das jetzt wirklich nicht?
Oh Kamera ist weg.
Machst du Mediaserver at home?
Nee, habe ich keinen Anwendungszweck für...
Ich weiß nicht, ich kann sich so genau nachvollziehen, warum Leute...
dann Plex und so bei sich lokal laufen.
Der einzige Grund, den ich mir vorstellen könnte ist, wenn die Leute beispielsweise zig Serien die letzten Jahre über sich sammelt haben und das dann vielleicht noch transcoden wollen, irgendwas, was der Fernseher richtig abspielen kann und so.
Aber ich hab seit Videos, also seit VODs und Video Streaming Services, ich hab lokal nichts mehr liegen an Videos. Ich hab sogar kaum Musik noch lokal liegen.
Also ich mein warum sollte ich petabyteweise irgendwelche Serien haben lokal wenn ich die
einfach bei irgendeinem Streaming Service gucken kann?
Muss man nicht verstehen.
War das nicht um zu zeigen wie das Dashboard umspringt beim klingeln?
Richtig du hast recht.
Tatsächlich das Tablet Dashboard war das hier was was umspringt.
ja ja genau das wollte ich zeigen das das wollte ich zeigen
ja ok dann fangen wir mal an also machen wir mal die idee auch vielleicht müssen
wir vielleicht mit den ganzen jet-brains-geschichten noch mal kurz
aktualisieren kurz gucken
jet-brains
was jetzt hat sich einfach selbst beendet ich glaube das updatet sich gerade
Ja, please restarten, ah da ist es wieder, so, Updates, das dauert jetzt wieder 3 Stunden
bis, also eins muss man dem JetBrains Zeugs, kann man dem JetBrains Zeugs ja nicht sagen,
dass es leichtgewichtig ist, das ist alles irgendwie gefühlt Terabyteweise Java Kram,
zur fleet ich kann dazu nichts sagen ich habe es nie ausprobiert ich habe nur mitbekommen dass
das released wurde verklappt gestern oder so oder am donderstag nicht letzte woche irgendwann ist
nicht lange her und irgendwie fragt sich so ziemlich jeder was soll man damit jetzt eigentlich machen
weil die meisten sachen gibt es ja eigene ideas für mit mehr funktionen ansonsten soll es relativ
Unstable sein und also ich wüsste jetzt nicht was das aktuell bringt jetzt für mich dass
ich das benutze
Oh, Sharepoint, MonkaS, was ist mit Sharepoint?
Wie schlimm ist Sharepoint und Microsoft zeuglich administrieren ist immer Painschamp.
Wie schwierig ist das Lernen von Enhyper?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob das überhaupt noch jemand richtig verwendet.
Ich kenn das ja, aber die meisten Leute, die irgendeinen OM-Mapper verwenden wollen unter
.NET, die nehmen eher Entity Framework Core, wohlgemerkt, nicht Entity Framework 6.
Also ist nicht irgendwie da 10 Jahre alter Kram.
Aber prinzipiell denke ich, ist der Umstieg, wenn man Java benutzt hat, auf C Sharp jetzt
nicht sonderlich schwierig.
Ich kann es aus erster Hand nicht sagen, weil ich verwende eigentlich nur.NET und kein Java.
Aber wenn ich mal Java Sachen lesen muss oder so, ist das eigentlich überhaupt kein Problem
und ich würde es wahrscheinlich auch hinkriegen und umgedreht ist es, denke ich, ähnlich.
Nö.
Ist das nicht die China-Chinesen-CPU?
Wie hast du eigentlich dein Netzwerk aufgebaut wegen dem China-Stuff?
Ich würde sowas auch machen, nur weiß ich nicht wie das angehen soll. Na am besten ist
Du machst für alles, dem du nicht wirklich vertraust ein eigenes WLAN
Am besten mit eigenem WLAN unten drunter
Dass das komplett abgeschottet ist, weil vielleicht willst du ja auch nicht nur WLAN Geräte, sondern auch in diesem gleichen
VLAN, versteht man so besser, wenn man es auf deutsch ausspricht
Noch irgendwelche kabelgebundenen Geräte haben oder so. Also machst einen VLAN für IoT
und dann kannst du dir das überlegen wie du das noch machen willst also entweder sagst du zum
Beispiel ich mache ein ich mache ein gehen wir erstmal auf wlan auf wlan ebene also du gehst
zum beispiel auf oh tanzverbot oder ist das fake nein tatsächlich cool ja schön dass du
deinen weg her gefunden hast ich weiß zwar nicht über welche wege aber da ist die sache
bin ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben
okay quaid
ach ja genau also wie ich mein wie ich mein wie ich mein netzwerk aufgebaut habe also
was ich dir empfehlen kann ist folgendes
Mach für jedes deine Anwendungszwecke eine, also eine eigene SSID, wenn du Gäste hast
bei dir, also nicht so wie ich, dass du quasi niemand kennst und niemand vorbeikommt, also
wenn du Gäste hast ab und zu und möchtest, dass du Gäste WLAN anbieten kannst, dann
mach eine Gäste SSID, dann mach eine SSID für alle deine WLAN Geräte, die dir sind,
die nicht zu den Gästen gehören und dann macht eine eigene SSID auf, also ein eigenes
WLAN auf für deine China-Chinesen-IoT-Geräte. Am besten machst du noch ein eigenes VLAN
unten drunter, dass das voneinander getrennt ist, aber das ist schon mal prinzipiell gut.
Da kannst du das nämlich auch unterschiedlich berechtigen. Da kannst du nämlich zum Beispiel,
falls du sowas machen willst, ich weiß ja nicht wie Rash4Bash, ich weiß ja nicht wie
Advanced du das bei dir aufbauen willst, da kannst du nämlich zum Beispiel sagen, wenn
Leute sich ins Gäste-WLAN einloggen, dann kommen sie auf eine Anmeldeseite oder du
hast denen, kannst du dann machen wie du willst, also kannst du denen zum Beispiel ein Token
geben, was sie eintippen müssen, dass dann halt nur die Gäste im Gäste-WLAN ins Internet
kommen, denen du so ein Token gegeben hast oder du lässt die sich beispielsweise einloggen
auf einer Webseite, wenn sie sich verbunden hat mit dem Gäste-WLAN.
Das kannst du machen, das willst du ja mit deinen eigenen Geräten nicht machen, deswegen
du dir ein eigenes WLAN, machst du eine eigene SSID auf für deine Tablets und dein Smartphone
und ja vielleicht für deinen Raspberry Pi und sonst was, was du rumstehen hast und das
China und das ist das wichtigste an der Stelle, dein China Stuff, das China-Chinesen Zeug,
das stellst du in ein eigenes WLAN. Wie gesagt, das sollte auch in einem eigenen Faulern drin
sein, dann hast du nämlich nicht das Problem, dass irgendwelche Änderungen auf IP-Ebene
zu führen, dass du einfach mal an irgendwelchen Firewalls vorbei kannst oder so.
Jo und dann, ähm, stellst du das so restriktiv ein, dass du, du meintest mal im Video hast
du ein Upload geblockt hast?
Ja genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen.
Also was du machen kannst ist folgendes, wenn du das Ding dann in einem eigenen VLAN stehen
hast, dann denkst du dir irgendeinen Netzwerkbereich aus für das Ding und dann blockst du einfach
alles was du nicht brauchst. Also du machst standardmäßig alles dicht, sowohl Internet-Zugriff
als auch Zugriff auf andere Netzwerke. Am besten ist natürlich eh du stellst deine
Firewall-Regel so ein, dass standardmäßig alles dicht ist, was du nicht erlaubt hast.
Oh, Updates fertig, nice. Ja, und dann gibst du Sachen frei, wie zum Beispiel NTP, weil
das brauchen viele China-Chinesen-Dinger, die funktionieren nicht richtig, wenn sie
die Zeit nicht abrufen können, kannst beispielsweise NTP auf deinen Router freigeben, Internetzugang
würde ich prinzipiell geblockt lassen, bei China Geräten, weiß ja nie so genau, ob dein
Staubsauger Roboter nicht doch irgendwie deine Wohnungspläne in die China Cloud schickt,
man kann jetzt sagen, ist nicht schlimm, wenn man damit keine Probleme hat, kann man das
auch freigeben, aber ich denke mir, man muss nicht mehr in die China Chinesen Cloud hochladen
als notwendig. Wenn ich das nicht juckt oder wenn es wichtig ist, dass die App funktioniert,
dann muss man das machen. Aber ich verwende halt prinzipiell nichts, was China Cloud und
China App braucht. Auch falls jetzt irgendjemand ankommt und sich wieder darüber aufregt,
dass es China Zeug ist. Es ist mir prinzipiell egal, ob das China Zeug ist. Ich verwende
so gut wie nichts, was cloudbasiert ist. Also nichts, wo ich die offizielle App benutzen
muss, dass ich dann das Gerät, was neben mir steht, übers Internet bedienen muss. Das
Das finde ich bescheuert, beispielsweise auch diese ganzen Ring-Door-Bells und Thermostate und was es nicht alles gibt.
Letztens gab es ein Problem bei AWS, also AWS ist ja eine ganze Amazon-Cloud-Geschichte und da konnten Leute ihre Heizung nicht mehr bedienen.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Leute, überlegt euch mal.
Ihr wollt eure Heizung einschalten beziehungsweise eure Thermostate ändern und es geht nicht.
Warum geht es nicht? Ja weil AWS gerade down ist.
Das ist doch, das ist doch total hängen geblieben, warum sollte man das machen?
User32DLL, danke für den Sub.
Das ist, das ist richtig bescheuert, also ganz im Ernst.
Mein Smart Home muss funktionieren lokal, wenn ich das will.
Okay, wenn man WLAN kaputt ist oder wenn mein Netzwerk im Arsch ist oder so, dann okay,
dann ja, dann ist klar, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Aber es sollte nicht durch einen puren Internetausfall nicht mehr funktionieren
oder aber abhängig sein von irgendwelchen Cloud-Services.
Wenn ich meine Heizung einschalten will, dann will ich jetzt meine Heizung einschalten und nicht noch 2 Stunden warten bis AWS wieder funktioniert oder bis Vodafone auf die Reihe gekriegt hat, dass mein Internetanschluss wieder funktioniert.
Also das muss nicht sein.
Und deswegen ist Cloud-basiertes Zeug ziemlicher Müll.
Also ihr kommt mir auch ehrlich gesagt nicht ins Haus, deswegen tue ich mir auch schwer, mir einen neuen Staubsauger-Roboter auszusuchen.
auszusuchen. Ich hatte ja einen, mit dem war ich nicht wirklich zufrieden, weil ich da auch keine
Möglichkeit habe mit automatischer Entleerungsstation und sowas. Die sind alle cloudbasiert, die sind
alle, nicht unbedingt China cloudbasiert, aber alle cloudbasiert und alle brauchen die offizielle
App. Und dann musst du dann im Endeffekt für ein Gerät, was neben dir steht, musst du dann mit der
App ins W-Land, von W-Land zu einem Server in den USA, in China oder sonst wohin, von dort wird
irgendwas berechnet dort geht es dann wieder zurück zu dir auf deinen Staubsauger-Roboter
der das ab.
Das ist doch hängen geblieben, warum kann ich nicht direkt meinen Staubsauger-Roboter
steuern?
Hast du eine Empfehlung für einen Thermostat?
Ja, aber was willst du für was haben?
Willst du eins haben für die Heizung im Keller oder willst du eins haben für die Heizkörper
in der Wohnung?
Also für was im Keller kann ich dir nichts empfehlen, ich kann dir nur einen Software-Projekt
empfehlen. Falls du eine Wiesmann Heizung hast, da würde ich nämlich gar nichts umstellen,
dann würde ich das hier verwenden. Das ist ein Open Source Projekt von GitHub, da kannst
du mit dem passenden Kabel deine Wiesmann Heizung steuern, ohne dass du was an der Steuerung
ändern musst, also dass du die Steuerung ausbauen musst. Dafür brauchst du ein Wiesmann
Optolink Kabel, so ein Ding zum dranstecken und ein Raspberry Pi, dann funktioniert das.
Du musst das da vorne einführen in die Heizung und dann kannst du die Sachen steuern und
auslesen.
So und wenn du auf der Suche bist nach Thermostaten für die Heizkörper, da gibt es jede Menge.
Ich persönlich muss sagen, ich bin mit den Dingern eigentlich ganz glücklich, auch wenn
die aktuell viel, viel zu teuer geworden sind bzw. gar nicht mehr lieferbar sind.
D.h. aktuell hast du ziemlich Pech, ne 302 ist das alte 302, gibt's aktuell nicht mehr
zu kaufen na geil also ich habe ich habe vier fritz thermostate bei mir ich habe
hier im arbeitszimmer 1 ich habe drüben im wohnzimmer 1 ich habe unten im flur
1 also was unten im flur im flur 1 das ist ja so zwei ebenen flur unten und
dann treppe hoch hier zu mir in den ersten stock hier wo es das arbeitszimmer
ist und warte mal wo habe ich denn das vierte ich habe arbeitszimmer wohnzimmer
Ach unten im Bad, fuck, unten im Bad hab ich noch eins, also ich hab vier von diesen Fritz
Thermostaten, das sind noch die alten, diese Teile, ich hab die noch, also bei mir haben
die noch irgendwie ein paar und vierzig Euro und ich hab sie im Pack gekauft, da waren
sie noch billiger, mittlerweile wollen die irgendwie sechzig Euro dafür haben, was
meiner Ansicht nach viel zu teuer ist, ganz im Ernst, was ist mit euch, 69 Euro für
ein Heizkörperthermostate, das ist doch, hast du Pepega oder, Tado war auch Cloud basiert
oder, wie oft wechselst du die Thermostate, die Batterien, wie oft wechselst du die Batterien
an thermostaten also ich habe das erste gekauft ich glaube vor zwei jahren im december und
da habe ich die batterien gewechselt irgendwann im august also so eins bis ich sag mal so
eineinhalb jahre wenn du es nicht viel verwendest
also wenn du nicht alle alle paar minuten dran rum schaltest ungefähr eineinhalb jahre das gute ist das wechsel ist ziemlich easy
du musst da auch nichts abschrauben also du kannst das von hand ein stückchen rumdrehen dann machst du die klappe auf
tauscht die batterie und machst die klappe wieder zu das justiert sich richtig und geht dann wieder
was ist mit den thermostaten von aliexpress tja da habe ich nur ein sig pi thermostat mal ausprobiert von den billy china chinesen dingern
Aber die sind Müll und die werden jetzt von akara verkauft also das ist diese diese dieses
Xiaomi Home Smart Home Brand was sie da haben das sind die gleichen Thermostate und die sind
bestimmt nicht besser geworden nur weil der jetzt akara drauf steht also die liga finde ich ganz
gut was wohl auch nicht schlecht sein muss hören sagen hören sagen turka das ist vielleicht was
für dich weil die sind lieferbar wenn du ein bisschen bastelfreundlich freundlich bist weil
HOMETIC an sich finde ich ziemlich pepega in der heutigen zeit da ich sich in HOMETIC system hinzustellen aber
Die thermostate sind nicht verkehrt, weil die thermostate
What the fuck warum ist das alles so teuer auf einmal?
Das letzte mal hat es noch 35 euro oder so gekostet leute
Warum ist das so teuer wir haben doch letztens zusammengeguckt 35 eur base 49 warum ist das
so teuer alles was ist denn mit euch los mann inflation in zwei wochen ja oh matic
Gucken wir mal, was Geizhals dazu sagt, okay 49, aber immerhin immerhin noch besser als 69 also
die sind angeblich gar nicht so gar nicht so schlecht Alter warum ist das so teuer alles
gerade ist doch nicht normal das ist ja krass alter was das alles kostet
mittlerweile ja allerdings muss man sagen um die betreiben zu können muss ein
bisschen trick 17 machen du brauchst auf jeden fall in
respiratory pie und mit home assistant oder iow broker oder open hub oder was
auch immer. Du kannst die ansteuern, aber halt nicht so einfach wie beispielsweise die Fritz-Dinger.
Also Fritz-Thermostate anzusteuern sind super simpel. Wenn du eine Fritz-Box hast oder du
nimmst die Home Assistant Integration. Ich würde es bei Aliexpress nicht, bei Aliexpress
die Dinger taugen nicht. Ganz ehrlich, bei Aliexpress hast du diese Zigbee-Thermostate,
die sind laut eklig in der bedienung also ich ich fand die nicht gut da hast du wirklich
keinen spaß dran ernsthaft das ist natürlich kacke moment das wollte ich gar nicht anklicken
Lul. Das wollte ich erklingen. Die Hormatik sein werden...
Das ist doch... Ah, das ist doch scheiße alles.
Du hast die Fritz-Thermostate gegen China getauscht. Viel besser.
Ah ja, gegen welche China denn?
Jetzt sag nicht diese komischen Akara Thermostate, weil die fand ich richtig mies.
Was?
Essentials?
Ok, jetzt schauen wir.
Schreiker 95 thermostate geheimtipp essentials thermostate
das geht ja wahrscheinlich auch wieder nur über cloud oder wenn ich schon tuja lese
dann ist es auf jeden fall cloud basiert man sieht ja nicht mal wie es ausschaut cloud
basierte thermostate ja gut internet internet zugang mal kurz weg ganz die heizung nicht anmachen
Echt ist in die sickb dann ist es okay
Ich sehe da nichts von sickb ach ja unten
Okay, dann können sie doch was taugen ja das dann ist okay dann ist in ordnung
Da sind in ordnung ich habe gerade eine nachricht gekriegt auto fertig geladen dauert 3,7 stunden wo wir es gerade von hatten
So wir müssen jetzt langsam mal anfangen hier mit basteln sonst wird das heute wieder
nix ich sag's euch.
So erst mal IDE starten, hast du mal nen Link zu denen, nicht die, nicht die, Essentials
Thermostat.
Wee Smartify Boah was ist das für ein Brocken man
Massive, Massive Klotz Die da, die da
Alter das sind paar Brocken eh Bauhauskeck
Das sind paar Brocken hier.
Amazon, ach bei Amazon, ah okay.
Doch, Alter, das sind die Dinger, die ich, nee das ist Müll, das fand ich ganz ganz
schrecklich.
Das hab ich mir schon vor Jahren gekauft, das war das erste Thermostat, was ich mir
gekauft habe.
Das ist laut as fuck, also vielleicht ist ja mittlerweile besser produziert, keine Ahnung, aber bei mir war es wirklich Müll.
Das ist laut as fuck. Es hat laufend ZigBee-Verbindungen verloren. Das zum Einstellen war irgendwie sehr schwammig mit diesem Ring.
Die Anzeige vorne war extrem blickwinkelabhängig, das heißt du hast eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts darauf erkannt.
das draufdrücken vorne hat dazu geführt dass das display geflaggert hat also das war ganz
großer müll dieses teil das hatte ich auch das war überhaupt nicht gefallen
Wie gut hast du deine Katze entzogen?
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht.
Die macht was sie will.
Das ist aber merkwürdig, da müssen die ja die letzten paar Jahre das Ding komplett
umgebaut haben.
Das wäre sehr China untypisch.
Also ich fand die Digger ganz schrecklich, das war nicht zu gebrauchen.
So jetzt fangen wir mal an mit mal zeit hier also das mal dicht
Wir brauchen welches projekt
Repos fiat client
Ne
Das da
Erdorn
Erster, yo öffnen please, trust
Ketchup
Alter ich kann nicht schreiben
Das war jetzt was, wie kann man sich bei einem vier Buchstabenwort so oft verschreiben?
Okay
Alles klar, mal eins, eine Sache machen wir mal kurz und zwar
mal kurz dotnet updaten ich weiß nicht ob es eine neue version von gibt dotnet 7 preview
nee rc haben wir doch sogar gibt es rc 2 schon rc 2 vor vier tagen das brauchen wir gib her
gib gib rc 2 excellent
not fully support oh jetzt habe ich gerade geupdatet ist
Oh, was denn da kaputt?
Please use language preview.
Mach ich.
Stellt man das um?
Okay
Das richtige überhaupt da drinnen
Alter was hat er denn hier drinnen mensch der soll das da benutzen gefälligst
Das kann mega abspacken.
Wir können gleich anfangen.
Jetzt sollte das aber eigentlich funktionieren Latest.
Ich hab 11.
Ah, geht doch.
Okay, also, was wir heute machen ist folgendes.
Wir haben ein paar Feature-Requests.
Oh, da hat einer was drauf geantwortet.
Sagt mal, es hat einer was drauf geantwortet und zwar, was wollte ich sagen, would it be
comme pos hardships
Can we add that unit of measurements to the HA8
Jaaaaa, das geht nicht so ohne weiteres
weil ich ja nicht weiß, was Sensors values sind, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal
Irgendwelche
Kokona Unit user
haben gefragt, ob man in meinem addon die sachen nicht
vielleicht anstatt von kilometer im miles ausgeben kann schickt die fiat cloud nicht
beide units nein die schicken nur kilometer so das heißt was wir jetzt machen werden ist
folgendes also home assistant habe ich geupdatet als erstes bauen wir mal eine lokale api für
fiat so fake lokale fake fiat api weil ich habe keinen bock immer anfragen an fiat zu schicken
um irgendwas auszuprobieren. Irgendwann bannen die mich noch, oder so, ja.
Jetzt heißt das mal, Fiat IP bannend, so nach dem Motto, der Kel macht nur zu viele Anfragen,
da stimmt irgendwas nicht. Also wir machen lokale Fake-API, dass ich dann auch ordentlich
mein Zeug ausprobieren kann. Dann probieren wir diese Kilometer, Kilometer zu, Kilometer
zu Miles. Conversion. Ist das Conversion? Ne, doch. Machen wir dann. Und wenn das funktioniert,
mal ob das automatische Imagebild auch funktioniert. Müssen wir mal schauen. Ja, da müssen wir noch
ChangeLog anpassen und wir müssen noch Versionsnummer anpassen und solche
Dinge machen. Aber das ist alles Bonus. Das hier ist das ist das ist das wichtig
erstmal, weil zurzeit ist es so, wenn ich mein Addon lokal starten will, dann macht
der anfragen jedes mal zu viert das ist halt doof ja so und ich will es ja hier lokal auf
meinem rechner starten moin sarex ich will es ja auch lokal auf meinem rechner starten
können und will nicht jedes mal die home assistant updaten und so was das das das
probieren wir jetzt mal also run run dotnet dotnet run ja ok was achso ein kilometer
gleich 0,62137
Ich habe ja nichts eingestellt. Ich habe weder Passwort übergeben noch sonst irgendwas
übergeben. Kein Wunder, dass das nicht funktioniert. Jetzt muss ich alles exportieren. Das ist
eigentlich kein großes Problem, weil ich habe das normalerweise schon bei mir in der
Shell Historie, aber hier habe ich nichts. Weil es ist ja so, wenn man dieses Addon installiert,
Ich zeige euch mal kurz wie das aussieht.
Also, man geht in den Addon Store.
Repository, das löschen wir jetzt erstmal.
Registries, ja.
Lokale Addons.
Das muss ich auch noch mal kurz alles löschen.
Root Add, ne nicht 25.
Sondern...
Das da.
Ich glaube das ist mein Home Assistant.
Zumindest den, den wir hier...
nicht doch ach so nicht cd alter ssh addons er-f alles weg sowohl das hello world addon
als auch der 4er champ comeback ist so und ich denke mal jetzt muss man wahrscheinlich
Home Assistant noch mal Rebooten, Check for Updates, ah ne, hat's erkannt, so, also wenn
man meinen Addon verwenden will, dann muss man das Repo als Addon Repo hinzufügen, machen
wir mal, so, und wenn man das drinne hat, dann sieht man irgendwo das Addon, man hat
übrigens mittlerweile auch Readme Datei und so, da kann man wirklich erkennen was ist,
dann klickt man auf Install, dann lädt sich das Image runter und dann kann ich solche
Sachen hier einstellen, wie mein User bei Fiat, Passwort für den User, Pin für
Commands, wie viele Minuten er das abrufen soll, plus Batteriestatus und
Location vom Auto refreshen und sowas. Da schreiben wir jetzt irgendwie rein
cackel-add-example.com, Passwort 123456, Pin 1234, save. Wenn ich das ganze jetzt
starte, werdet ihr feststellen, es funktioniert nicht, weil wer hätte das
gedacht? Oh, bitte! Invalid Login ID! Also, wer hätte gedacht, dass cackle-at-example.com
nicht funktioniert? So, und das ist natürlich ein bisschen doof, weil ich kann das jetzt
nicht ausprobieren, lokal, ohne dass ich einen gültigen Account eingebe und dass ich laufend
Requests an Fiat schicke. Deswegen faken wir das jetzt mal. Ja, wie? Ja, verstehe ich
auch nicht verstehe ich auch nicht warum warum akzeptiert fiat nicht kackel example der mock
champ fällt aber sarex der fällt etwas kleiner aus als es jetzt vielleicht vorstellt weil wir
mock champ nicht die ganze api sondern wir machen einfach ein vier ein fake fiat client also das ist
das problem ich kann es lokal nicht gescheit ausprobieren vor allem mit fake accounts kann
ich auch nicht ausprobieren das ist das erste was wir jetzt einbauen bevor wir uns um diese
sachen mit kilometer zu meilen kümmern so und wir machen das folgendermaßen ich habe mir das
nämlich schon überlegt im vorfeld ihr könnt quasi sagen ich habe gecheatet wir machen hier
ein extra ein extra feld rein so was wie use fake api und wenn ich das wenn ich
den parameter übergebe dass ich die fake api benutzen will dann benutzt er dann
später das was ich lokal gespeichert habe so damit ich das starten kann muss
ich erstmal ein Mist angeben von Optionen. Das ist jetzt erstmal wir. Also ich kann
doch hier, ich versuche das mal ungefähr zu erklären, dass man den Anfang zumindest
checkt. Also ich kann doch in dem Addon, in diesen Config Settings jede Menge Zeug eingeben.
Und das funktioniert dann folgendermaßen, wenn Home Assistant das Addon startet, dann
wird das quasi als Environment Variablen übergeben an mein Programm und ich kann
drauf zugreifen hier guck add environment variables variables das habe ich natürlich
nicht wenn ich lokal laufen lasse weil dann starte ich ja selbst hier aus der kommando zeile und
nicht als als home assistant addon deswegen muss ich das ganze quasi jetzt so tun als wäre ich ein
home assistant muss dann sagen export muss man zum glück nur einmal machen export via user
ich bin jetzt gar nicht sicher, field is required ok mal gucken ob er sich jetzt über was anderes
meckert. Vielleicht noch andere lützliche Lenkeinheiten einbauen. Feed und die Leistung,
die rechnen wir auch in BTU pro Stunde um. In Badewannen, top. In Ellen, könnte man
noch ellen und und in fußballfelder aber irgendjemand hatte doch eine ziemlich gute
idee eben das habe ich das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben
irgendjemand hatte doch eine gute guten vorschlag für
die api konvertierung kurz chat gucken also nicht nicht die nicht die maßeinheiten
ach nee das war aus dem ticket das war aus dem ticket das das mit dem sensor ja das probieren
wir dann aus das mit dem sensor das müssen wir gleich mal gucken also app config also
er hat fiat user hat er gecheckt ok also export fiat user das ist jetzt einmal
einmal fleißarbeit fiat pw brauchen wir da noch ja ok dann brauchen wir
mqtt server da muss ich jetzt was richtiges reinschreiben nämlich diesen
da den da 1 3 2 was brauchen wir als nächstes
was brauchen wir als nächstes mqtt server mqtt password brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich als nächstes ah ne user ich denke mal so wie ich mich kenne ist
das wahrscheinlich sowas und das password ist 123456 chat wollen wir wetten
Der User ist MQTT und das Passwort ist 123456, ihr kennt mich das, meine Passwörter sind
immer so, so high IQ.
Refresh-Intervalle müssen wir nicht setzen, Autorefresh brauchen wir auch nicht, das brauchen
wir auch nicht.
useFakeAPI brauchen wir aber, wobei schauen wir mal kurz ob es jetzt schon funktioniert
run, aha, oh, verbitten invalid login id, ja gut die gibt es ja auch nicht, aber es
startet schon mal, die gibt es ja auch nicht, fiat user 0 und fiat password 0w, ja das
funktioniert nicht, aber es startet schon mal. Dann sagen wir jetzt noch Export Use Fake
RP Katze123 ja auch gutes Passwort. Und wir sagen noch Export Def Mode, das ist das er
Zeug anhängt vor dem Auto, dass ich meine eigentliche Sachen nicht überschreibe, die
die schon drin sind. Magic machen wir einmal, muss er jetzt nicht
weiter interessieren. Zumindest wichtig ist, dass den Kram jetzt
lokal ausführen kann. Er versucht zu starten, er kann sich natürlich
nicht bei Fiat einloggen, deswegen machen wir jetzt mal ein Fake der Fiat API und zwar
Normalerweise funktioniert das so, wenn er startet, dann übergibt er den eingetippten
Usernamen und den eingetippten Passwort an der Stelle an diese Fiat-Klasse und die macht
ein Login, dann loggt er sich ein bei Fiat, macht ganz
abstruse sachen was man machen muss weil es nicht anders funktioniert, weil Fiat sich
gedacht hat, das ist eine gute idee und danach ruft er sich sachen von von Fiat ab ja zum
Beispiel zum Beispiel wie viele autos ich dort habe und den status so sieht dann folgendermaßen
aus weil ich habe das schon mal vorbereitet sieht dann folgendermaßen aus moment ich
Ich muss mal kurz in mein lokales Repo.
Oh, hab ich das?
Das kopier ich mir jetzt nämlich einfach raus.
Ich werd das jetzt nicht alles nochmal abtippen.
Ähm.
Was ist mit der Musik los?
Genau, also das erste was wir jetzt brauchen ist erstmal ein Interface, iFiat Klein, mir
fällt nichts besseres ein und also das Ziel ist ja folgendes, wenn ich diesen Parameter
gesetzt habe hier use fake api wenn ich den gesetzt habe dann will ich ja
nicht den normalen fiat client verwenden sondern einen fake fiat client also abconfig
use fake api so hier muss dann quasi tja new fake fiat client hin und hier kommt dann
der andere. So, das müssen wir jetzt natürlich noch bauen, dass es das überhaupt gibt. Und
an allen Stellen, ja, ich kopiere mir das mal, weil das habe ich tatsächlich schon fertig.
Tobias STL lang schon für den Sub. Das habe ich tatsächlich schon fertig, weil das sehr
viel Copy Pasten war. Da habe ich keinen Bock, das hier im Stream zu machen. Ich zeige euch
einfach mal das fertige ist nichts ist nicht super kompliziertes zeug dabei ist nur viel
nur viel copy paste krempel gewesen so hier achtung wupp fertig was das ding jetzt macht
ist wir haben jetzt beide vier also wir haben den fake fiat klein und den echten fiat klein
der zur richtigen Apo geht, beides erbt von iFiat klein, das heißt das ist das was ich
hier drin verwende und das hier ist der mit Fake Daten, login macht da gar nichts, commands
senden macht da auch nichts, aber Autos abrufen macht er und zwar mit Fake Daten, der ruft
ein Auto ab, sieht so aus, ich hab JasonResponses einfach mitgeschnitten und die dann bisschen
umgeschrieben und infos für das auto ruft er hier auch ab also quasi echte responses von der fiat api nur ein bisschen
anonymisiert also von meinem auto nur ein bisschen anonymisiert
So sieht es aus
und
läng grad 69
breiten grad 69
Weiß gar nicht wo das ist wollen wir kurz gucken wo mein auto angeblich steht
Weiß gar nicht, wie man das auf Google Maps überhaupt eingeben kann.
Wie gämpft man das auf Google Maps noch mal richtig ein?
So einfach?
Ja
Existiert anscheinend nicht
Ach hier ist das ok irgendwo im mehr
Südwestlich von Sri Lanka
Ist mein auto gerade maletiven alles klar hier
Captain iglo
Irgendwo da steht mein auto arabisches
Ja kommt mal vorbei also da ist das da ist das laut laut dem hier gerade
Gut, und jetzt haben wir den Vorteil, jetzt können wir nämlich Daten abrufen, ohne jedes
Mal zu Fiat zu gehen, nämlich einfach mit dieser Fake API hier.
So, jetzt müssen wir noch ändern, dass die nicht den Fiat Client, sondern iFiat Client
verwenden.
So und jetzt sollte es eigentlich funktionieren wenn ich es jetzt starte
Sieht schon besser aus
Habt ihr übrigens gesehen dass ich jetzt auch gescheites logging auf dem terminal habe und nicht mehr nur command-line
right line man kann tatsächlich jetzt damit was anfangen ok so der export ist gelaufen gucken
wir mal ob alles funktioniert hat integrations mqtt oder gibt es jetzt ein keckel def das ist mein
auto besser name gut hat aber alles hat funktioniert also ich kann kommandos schicken an mein auto an
mein fake auto was es ja eigentlich gar nicht gibt ja ich kann lichter blinken lassen ich kann
charging starten batterie status update und sonst was location update machen kofferraum auf
klimaanlage an und aus und hier sehen wir beispielsweise auch die location die location
ist wie gesagt hier irgendwo im arabischen meer gerade und dann hat man solche dinger hier
charging level ist gerade am aufladen distance in kilometer das ist eines der dinger die halt
den amis nicht gefällt also distance bis es leer wie viel kilometer kann ich
noch fahren bis es leer ist 172 kilometer und sowas das bekommt man
normalerweise bekommt man das direkt von der fiat api jetzt ist das halt der
mitgeschnittene response von der fiat api was insofern ganz wichtig ist
sonst bannen die mich irgendwann wenn ich da im sekundentakt bei mir
irgendwelche anfragen schicke das heißt das an der stelle funktioniert schon hätten mich
jetzt aber auch gewundert wenn es nicht funktioniert weil das habe ich im vorfeld schon ausprobiert
jetzt gucken wir mal ob wir diesen feature request irgendwie umgesetzt kriegen also der
Der erste hätte gerne, dass die Kilometer-Exports, also das hier zum Beispiel, dass es in Meilen
umgerechnet wird und der andere, der hat tatsächlich eine relativ gute Idee, man könnte in Home
Assistant Unit of Measurement setzen.
Man kann, wenn man das exportiert in Home Assistant, also wenn ich diesen Wert hier exportiere,
kann man zu diesem Sensor dazu noch exportieren, in welcher Einheit das eigentlich ist.
Ich weiß bloß nicht, ob das so einfach ist.
Wir probieren erstmal die Hardcoded Variante aus.
Es ist ein bisschen fehleranfällig das ganze, weil ich weiß ja nicht, was mir die Fiat
Api alles zurückliefert, ja heute, morgen können das diese drei Werte nicht mehr sein
und dafür drei neue Werte, also falls sich die Fiat Api mal ändert, sollte das ja nicht
gleich kaputt gehen alles.
Ich gehe nicht davon aus, dass sich die Fiat Api großartig ändert ohne neue Version von
Api, weil, also rein aus einem logischen Grund, die Leute bei Fiat können sich ja nicht darauf
verlassen, dass ihre Kunden immer die aktuellste App-Version verwenden. Vielleicht haben ja
Leute ein bisschen ältere iPhones oder ein bisschen ältere Android-Geräte mit älteren
App-Versionen, es gibt keine neue App-Version. Also sprich, wenn die ihre interne Api ändern
würden ohne neue Versionsnummer für ihre Api bzw. neue URLs, dann würden sie die
App bei ganz vielen Leuten kaputt machen, die noch keine aktuelle Version haben. Und
Ich glaube, da sind sie nicht so scharf drauf, deswegen denke ich, dass sich in der API bei
Fiat gar nicht so viel ändern wird, aber man weiß es halt nicht.
Das heißt, es sollte nicht gleich kaputt gehen, nur weil Fiat da irgendwie zwei neue Werte
reinschreibt.
So, und ich kann auch jetzt nicht bei jedem, man sieht es hier, ich kann auch nicht bei
jedem Sensor einen Wert hinschreiben, weil ich ja keine Ahnung habe, was Fiat eigentlich
Dafür werte schickt ein was weiß ich wo soll ich wissen was ist das eigentlich für ein wert ja
ev info scheduled array 1 wahrscheinlich
Ja
Nun was soll es sein ich weiß es nicht das weiß nur fiat array 1
Also das heißt ich muss jetzt ein bisschen tricksen man könnte zum beispiel gucken wenn
Die unit
Wenn die Unit am Ende mit Kilometer endet, dann nehme ich das Value und rechne es um
in miles.
So was in dieser Richtung, das könnte funktionieren.
Und wenn das geht, guck ich mal ob ich das beim Sensor setzen kann, das wäre möglich.
Was geplante Ladung, Klimatisierung?
Was möchtest du mir genau sagen?
Das Tofai fährt für mich, das Kommen, das check ich grad nicht.
So, wir versuchen das mal umzubauen, irgendwie einzubauen mit Meilen.
Also
Wenn standort in den usa dann in meilen pro stunden ne das das mache ich nicht machen kommt ne ne das das machen wir nicht wir machen
Da steht die in den resten
geplante ladung ach so ok ja siehst du was hat das für eine einheit
Ich glaube es gibt keine ein in stunden vielleicht oder was das was weiß nicht
Wir filtern das nach Kilometer, ne Standort ist blöd, ich werde das so machen, es gibt
dann hier einfach eine neue Option, es gibt dann hier einen neuen Button, Convert Kilometer
to Miles und das kann man dann anhaken oder abhaken und so gut ist.
Wie nennt man das eigentlich, wenn man ein Häkchen wegmacht, das kann ja nicht abhaken
heißen oder?
Anhaken, okay, aber abhaken, ich glaube das gibt's nicht, ich glaube da gibt's kein
Wort für, ich glaube es gibt nur abhaken was eigentlich ein Häkchen ist und deselektieren
auch das ist gut, weghaken, abwählen finde ich gut, abwählen klingt wie die Microsoft
Übersetzung, das könnte wahrscheinlich echt so sein, also sprich wir müssen jetzt alle
alle Elemente durchgehen, also for each, details, ne, das ist falsch, alle, alle Elemente durchgehen
von diesem Teil hier, Moment, hier, guck mal, dieses, dieses komplette Chasing müssen
jetzt durchgehen, also von der Logik, von der Logik wird das folgendermaßen sein.
Der geht alle Elemente durch, schaut ob er ein Element findet was Unit heißt, mit einem
Value Kilometer. Wenn er was findet, dann geht er zum Parent
hoch, holt sich dann dort das Value raus, wenn das existiert, rechnet er dieses Value
in Meilen um und ändert die Unit von Kilometer auf Meils.
Was soll da schon schief gehen?
Also, so, alle Elemente unterhalb von meinem Hut-Element.
Du willst die Meilen auf 12 Nachkommas stellen?
Warte, was haben wir denn?
Ich glaube dass ich ich glaube das ist nur ein einfaches float ich glaube das hört bei irgendwie sechs nachkommas stellen oder so
oder aber insgesamt
Ja, ich glaube über sechs nachkommas stellen oder so auf aber acht nachkommas stellen
overlay dankeschön für den sub
Du spürst den regex nee ohne regex keck alter null regex machen wir hier nicht
Wobei das stimmt gar nicht dass wir regex nicht machen
Ich bin ja einer der wenigen habe ich das Gefühl auf der Welt der Regex mag
Chat wer mag Regex von euch oder wer macht gern ekliche Sachen mit Regex
Wollen wir mal Umfrage machen, wir machen mal Umfrage.
Rek-Ex, Pog, not Pog.
Also Pog heißt gut, not Pog heißt schlecht.
Wer den Twitch-E-Mouse nicht so mächtig ist.
Okay, ist eine ziemlich geteilte Meinung, wie es ausschaut.
Ja, Netflix, die erzählen alle viel, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Es gibt auch ein weiteres, es gibt auch ein weiteres Sprichwort.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das gibt, wenn nicht, sage ich das jetzt.
Wenn einer sagt NEVER, dann ist es niemals NEVER, beziehungsweise dann ist es Blödsinn.
Wisst ihr wie ich meine, wenn einer sagt man soll niemals das machen, doch es gibt immer
Fälle wo man das machen sollte.
Also sagen wir mal ungefähr ein Drittel mag keine Regex Geschichten und das andere Drittel
Findet regex pock ich muss sagen ich zähle mich auch zur regex pock fraktion
Wahrscheinlich brauchen wir hier gar kein regex
Niemals suze die lungs nutzen ja das sehe ich genauso
Suze ist eklig
Okay also lasst mal kurz überlegen wie könnte man das ganze jetzt machen also wir gehen
jetzt quasi dieses Jason Array durch und wir suchen was das Unit heißt und das Value Kilometer
hat.
Okay bedeutet im Endeffekt das ist ja noch quasi gepasstes Jason wir müssen jetzt gucken
If dieses Token, wir nennen es Token, ansonsten ist es Token, Token, Token, Token, wunderbar.
Ist das Token ein Property, also sprich ist das ein Element mit Key Value und nicht mit
weiteren Elementen drunter?
So, hat dieses Token einen Key?
Hat dieses Token, oh ne wir können neues Pattern Matching verwenden Leute, Massive.
Oh, wie geht denn das so?
Nee, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ähm, so. So geht das, ne?
Ja, haha. Name is.
Was hab ich gesagt? Unit, gell? Name ist Unit.
Name ist Unit und.
Value ist Kilometer. Nice, ne?
das geht nicht als string ok also so das wird das wird jetzt eklig ich sehe schon kommen
und und so dieses property value to string gleich kilometer ok vielleicht nur bei bestimmten keys
Das machen wir gerade das machen wir gerade wir suchen uns nur alle kies raus die kilometer als unit haben und
Beispiel da gibt es ja auch welche wie wie druck für den reifen die wollen wir nicht umrechnen also wir gucken jetzt von der logik her
Wo gibt es einheit wo gibt es werte mit kilometer unit und diese werte rechnen wir dann um also sprich wir gucken
Wo gibt es hier einen adjacent objekt was als key unit hat als value kilometer dann gehen wir zum parent rauf
zum parent runter in ein value
property und davon holen wir uns dann den value
raus und rechnen um so so weit die theorie mal gucken ob das jetzt gescheit funktionieren also lasst mal kurz überlegen ist es
units
gleich kilometer das heißt wir matchen ich gebe sekunde ich gebe das mal kurz aus ob das irgendwie sind was zum
Poken, please. So. Gut. Schau mal. Der sollte jetzt mal alle Units ausgeben, die Kilometer,
den Wert haben mit Kilometer. Ja, okay, das sieht schon mal ganz gut aus. Das, das sieht
tatsächlich ganz rauchbar aus. So, also, wir sind jetzt hier an der Stelle. Wir haben
jetzt den hier gefunden. Das heißt, ich muss jetzt eins nach oben. Parent. In dem Parent
muss ich gucken ob die ein value haben also ein ein ein property haben was value
heißt und zu string und dann muss ich das ich schreibe das jetzt erst mal so
dreckig hin wie es mir einfällt und dann muss ich gucken ob sich das als int
Pasen lässt
Okay, das geht bestimmt irgendwie, ein, bisschen besser also lässt sich das als in parsen
value war out das ist keiner kilometer value dann
Ne out war so rum
kilometer value
So mal schauen was da jetzt rauskommt
double
Ja warum nicht komm leute wir sind wir sind ganz furchtbar genau double wir brauchen das doppelt genau
Hallo
Guck mal sogar der intellisens von meiner ide ist am abkacken
So, mal schauen, ob da jetzt Kilometerwerte rauskommen, sinnvolle Kilometerwerte.
Ja, Alicjum, vielleicht schreiben wir das eh nochmal um, das gefällt mir eh nicht.
das sieht schon mal ganz ganz relativ relativ sinnvoll aus so und jetzt müssen wir das
umrechnen in miles war miles also was war das mal 0,6 chat irgendjemand hat es vorhin
geschrieben Kilometer to miles 0,621371 so das ist jetzt in miles jetzt muss ich das
quasi ändern also sprich das da ist jetzt quasi nicht mehr kilometer sondern in miles
und mein property selber hat als value dann nicht mehr kilometer sondern miles ach du scheiße
das versteht doch keiner mehr so und wenn das funktioniert hat loggen wir mal was
sodass ich sehe in orange und sagen jetzt keine ahnung converted kilometer to miles
kilometer value miles well bam bin mal gespannt ob das funktioniert
Das scheint zu funktionieren, es gibt keine exceptions und sonst was?
Ok, das scheint zu klappen, Max sagt das wäre genauer, ist das denn auch wirklich so?
Ok, was haben wir denn hier zu bieten?
Das da versus das da, also es ist im Prinzip einfach nur noch ein paar Stellen genauer.
Ja, wenn wir eh schon ein Double haben, dann machen wir es ein paar Stellen genauer.
Leute, Massive, Massive genau.
Erstmal Units net installieren für die Konvertierung, das ist eine richtig gute Idee.
Ich habe
Ach wie hieß das denn ich hatte doch mal so eine coole konvert library gefunden hier von
schon eine ganze weile her
Die auch die konnte nicht nur konvertieren die konnte das ganze auch konvertieren in in menschen lesbar
also sprich die hat da nicht angezeigt 90 minuten sondern irgendwie 45 minutes ago und sowas
war das humanizer weiß ich
kilometer ich glaube für diese eine berechnung brauchen wir tatsächlich keine abhängigkeit
aber wie haben die das denn definiert dass das das gucken wir das gucken wir uns tatsächlich
mal an wie die das machen es kann sein dass ich humanizer meine aber dann war das nicht die die
wo ist es denn hier überhaupt und wo ist hier der source code da, wo könnte das jetzt stehen
kilometer miles speed das ist es ist nicht längs und da längs müssen wir gucken ok
Schauen wir mal wo wir das haben. Würde mich interessieren wie die das gemacht haben.
Was? Base? Meinst du?
Ne. Ne ne.
Ilo? Wenn ich aber noch richtig schreiben könnte.
Längs, Längs Unit, was zum, ich blicke hier schon wieder nicht durch. Unit, Converter,
Wir suchen mal nach miles
Was 2 miles per uk
Man kann auch wirklich bullshit in länder konvertieren
mensch das muss doch hier irgendwo stehen wo ist hier die konvertierung von miles
das sind alles tests ich will nicht die tests sehen ich will die eigentlichen
Fuck man, ich krieg noch BTU, Alter wie kann man so ne Unit konvertiert Library bauen,
dass man nix findet man?
Das wird gerne, aber anhand von was, der muss doch irgendwo, irgendwo muss doch stehen
wie er das umrechnet.
Units, hier, Miles, Length, Length, Miles, Nautical Miles, Monka S-Mann,
Units net common units ok guck mal gleich
Weil
Okay, das massive 6 hat library alter
Units net
Kamen ist es
Ach da hätte ich ja nie reingeguckt unit definitions aha
ja das sieht das sieht besser aus
ok mile wie machen die das hier miles was base unit mile data
Ich bin zu pepega hier irgendwie was zu checken gerade
Hey ja from hier das da oder
Ach from base to uniform base
Okay keine ahnung
Aber ich glaube ich glaube so können wir damit leben also
Kilometer mal 0,6 2 1 3 7 1 1 9
Hast du Pläne für zukünftige Videos auf YouTube?
Nein, ich hab jetzt aufgehört auf YouTube, instant.
Ja klar hab ich noch zukünftige Pläne für Videos.
Warum sollte ich auf einmal aufhören, die Videos hochzuladen?
Oder willst du wissen, was ich mir schon überlegt habe, was es für Themen gibt in nächster Zeit?
ja es gibt auf jeden fall noch das video zum internetausbau was ich schon vor
der woche machen wollte aber nicht gemacht habe ich habe eine ganz lange
liste die heißt bei mir weihnachtskalender bescheuert das das das
das textdokument heißt weihnachtskalender ich habe irgendwann mal
angefangen in einem textdokument was weihnachtskalender heißt ideen aufzuschreiben hat mit dem weihnachtskalender
nichts zu tun was sind g.cs dateien das sind die kommen aus dem generator sind aber ganz
normales die schaap dateien machst du advent of code so also wir gucken jetzt ob das funktioniert
hier es sollte das doch eigentlich schon jetzt alles exportieren oder sehe ich doch sehe ich
doch richtig
Internetausbau in Deutschland ist wieder wirklich ich sage euch wie es ist Ansage mit fail wieder wir haben ja jetzt
neue
Ja, weiß ich ob das ein gesetz ist ich glaube nicht sonst muss man sich ja dran halten neue
Pläne auf jeden fall und zwar soll bis
2025 60 prozent aller haushalte mit gigabit versorgt werden das schaffen die auch 60 prozent sind meistens nicht das problem aber
Aber bis 2030 alle haushalte mit gigabit
Was anderes kann ich dazu nicht sagen also sprich die müssen jetzt
Auch den letzten Bauernhof und die letzten Opas die das nicht wollen
Gut, was heißt nicht wollen zwingen kannst du keinen ins haus zu legen sondern kannst du das angebot machen das problem dabei wird sein
dass sich das einfach wieder wahnsinnig lange hinzieht und unabhängig davon wie realistisch
es ist dass man das schaffen kann oder nicht ein punkt der schon mal grundsätzlich daran
zweifeln zweifeln lässt wir haben breitband ziele seit fragt mich nicht deutschland hat
breitband ziele seit 1995 oder sowas Geschichte weiß ich ob es dann überhaupt eine übersicht
gibt also wir haben breitband ziele seit fragt mich 1997 und wir haben noch nicht einmal erzählt
mir sagt wenn ich falsch lege mir ist kein fall bekannt wir haben es nicht einmal geschafft seit
1997 die breitband ziele einzuhalten das heißt die große preisfrage ist warum glaubt man daran
dass diese nächsten breitband ziele eingehalten werden
ich kann sie mir ja nicht vorstellen so gucken wir mal ob die konvertierung funktioniert hat
in meilen ey guck mal wir haben es in miles
für unsere kokona friends haben wir jetzt anstatt kilometer haben wir es in miles guck
davor war es noch in kilometer und jetzt ist es in miles und und es ist dann auch 106 noch
war es anstatt irgendwie was war es vorher 170 kilometer wobei man sagen muss die lösung
hier ist weder schön zu lesen, noch ist das schön gemacht.
Tickets schließen miles, wenn ich supporte.
Easy.
Den Vorschlag von ihm hier finde ich gar nicht schlecht.
Unit of measurement in die Home Assistant Sensor Class.
Was gibt es denn für Unit of Measurements?
Muss ich das dann in Meter oder in Kilometer oder in Meilen oder?
Unit, was kann denn Home Assistant, Längen, Kilometer, Miles, M-E, ok, ok mal gucken ob
man das irgendwie eingebaut kriegt in meine sensor in in meinen sensor kram home assistant
ha ha sensor das müsste das müssten wir da eigentlich reinkriegen unit of measurement
wie könnte man das da einbauen aktuell habe ich das absichtlich mega simpel gehalten
exportiere mehr oder weniger eins zu eins was die ap ausspuckt ins home assistant format aber man
könnte hier natürlich tatsächlich unit of measurement dabei machen so was hier in der
und die unit ist halt standardmäßig wobei
Unit in Constructor oder Unit über Property, eigentlich ist das egal.
Ja komm wir machen hier Private Read Only String Unit und standardmäßig ist es einfach
leer.
Chet, seid ihr String Empty Benutzer oder macht ihr so?
Ich persönlich mache immer das da aber ich habe schon leute gehört die gesagt haben magst du geht das aber nicht benutzt gefällig string empty
Wobei das genau das gleiche ist das macht ja eigentlich kein unterschied
Hast du mal über ein studium nachgedacht ja
Yep habe ich mache ich aber nicht
Ich meine warum sollte ich jetzt studieren wer bescheuern
ich verdiene danach auch nicht mehr geld und ich verdiene in der zeit kein geld und und
ich muss mich anstrengen also ich könnte quasi easy easy live machen youtube twitch arbeiten
geld verdienen und oder ich könnte studieren gehen und kein geld verdienen und das andere
nicht machen und müssen mich anstrengen dafür mit nachdenken und aufpassen und so was warum
Sollte studieren
Bist du sicher dass du nicht mehr verdienst danach ja ich war in im durchschnitt selbstverständlich im durchschnitt verdienst du danach mehr
Aber wenn ich jetzt zu meinem chef gehen und sagt alter ich bin jetzt mal ich würde nicht sagen alter
Aber ich würde sagen alter ich bin jetzt mal kurz
Zweieinhalb drei jahre weg und studiere
Er wird dann sagen, ja finde er nicht gut, aber ich kriege danach sicherlich nicht mehr
Geld, weil ich mache ja genau das gleiche danach wie jetzt.
Und es ist ja auch nicht wirklich so als bräuchte ich da großartig den wissenschaftlichen Background
oder so bei der Sache was ich mache.
Ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich irgendwie Algorithmenlaufzeit mathematisch belegen muss oder beweisen muss
oder sowas.
Nebenberuflich
Nebenberuflich verdiene ich also youtube und twitch ist es doch egal ob ich fast studiert habe oder nicht
Oder meinst du es krieg ich habe mehr prime abos wenn ich studiert habe oder mehr subscriber auf youtube ich meine ich könnte ein
bisschen content da drüber machen ja aber ansonsten
Nä
außerdem bist du ja ganz im ernst das ist mir zu anstrengend ich sage es wie es ist
ich bin da viel zu faul für das studium nebenberuflich machen das ist ja noch schlimmer dann müsste
ich arbeiten gehen youtube machen twitch machen und studieren und leben du kannst doch klicken
da habe ich ja keinen spaß mehr am leben mehr ne ne das meine ich also es hat für mich
ja im Prinzip kein Vorteil in der aktuellen Situation irgendwie zu studieren, außer dass
ich weniger Geld verdienen würde zwischenzeitlich, mich mehr anstrengen müsste, weniger YouTube
und Twitch machen könnte, also ich würde quasi easy life, easy money zu weniger money
und mehr Anstrengung umtauschen, warum sollte ich das machen?
Ne, das mach ich nicht.
Es ist ja auch nicht so, dass es easy ist.
Also es gibt genug Leute, die sagen, ja ich weiß das eh schon alles, ich studiere nebenbei,
die werden dann aber relativ schnell drauf kommen, dass es nicht so ist.
Warum schreibst du den Code nicht direkt in Vim?
Weil ich mich nicht quälen will.
meine units so
ok gucken wir mal ob das funktioniert, string empty, was willst du von mir, ist ignored,
Ignored ach so doch ist ignore
Standardmäßig ist es
Exzellent alles klar so und jetzt exportieren wir die unit
Schon mal helix als wim ersatz getestet. Nee
Mir bringt helix auch nix als wim ersatz ich meine ich verwende natürlich wim ab und zu mal hier lokal auf der kommando zeile
Aber gerade Remote auf System verwende ich Wim um was zu editieren und da wirst du kein
Helix drauf kriegen.
So wie kriege ich denn jetzt?
So hier, lasst mal kurz gucken.
Details Sensor
Was muss ich denn da jetzt machen, dass das richtig, dass das Home Assistant checkt?
also sprich ich guck jetzt ob es mit miles endet
ey das ist doch bescheuert ich muss jetzt gucken endet es mit miles dann ist die unit
Miles ok war unit gleich
Sensor data
Aller ich verstehe mein eigenes zeug nicht mehr sensor data key
endet endet mit mit mit unit und sensor value ist dann ist kilometer ok so rum genau also
ja ja so ok das ergibt das ergibt sind ok also das mit das müssen wir alles noch mal schöner
Das gefällt das gefällt mir so nicht aber mal gucken ob das prinzipiell funktionieren würde was der kerl sich da so vorstellt also
Meine unit so also wenn im unit fällt es kilometer sind dann
Möchte ich haben das unit
Kilometer ist oder kilometer genau genau
Kilometer so und ansonsten
Ansonsten, Mai, was übrigens nicht stimmt, was nicht funktioniert, sag ich gleich, weil
ich hab ganz viele Felder, wo das halt nicht Miles ist.
So, also dann ist es Kilometer, dann ist es Mai, gut, so, wie könnte ich da jetzt irgendwie
ein Pattern Matching draus machen, dass das funktioniert?
Switch, da bin ich noch nicht so, das krieg ich noch nicht so aus dem Kopf hin, Switch
on, Moment, Switch Pattern Matching C Sharp, da krieg ich die Syntax immer nicht gebacken.
Samuel, Dankeschön für den Sub, Massive-Subscription, Dankeschön hier, Massive-Subscription.
Gibt es einen Raspberry Pi Alternativen mit SATA auch vielleicht schnell?
Es gibt einige Raspberry Pi Alternativen bzw. Single Board Computer, aber die kommen halt
alle nicht an den Raspberry Pi dran.
Die sind vielleicht schneller, die haben vielleicht SATA Anschluss, aber die haben nicht das Ökosystem
wie in Raspberry Pi an Header, an Boards, an Tutorials, an Material.
Also ich kann eigentlich nichts anderes empfehlen als den Raspberry Pi, wenn du was anderes haben willst als den Raspberry Pi, dann nimm dir ein Low-Power x86 Mainboard
mit aufgelöteter CPU oder mit CPU die standardmäßig drauf ist. Die brauchen auch nicht so viel mehr, die sind auch nicht so krass groß
Ja, irgendwie so ein so ein ITX
5 Dings, 5 0 4 0, irgendwie so so Dinger hier
die sind auch nicht groß und das aufgelötete cpu passiv hast sata hast du gerne pizzi express
die sind nicht so viel größer und raspberry pi ist ungefähr so groß hier viermal so groß so
ungefähr ein viertel davon ist ein raspberry pi wir brauchen nicht wirklich viel mehr strom
als ein raspberry pi 4 im idol und haben viel mehr viel mehr wums und haben auch mehr ios
dann würde ich gleich sowas nehmen gogo monshi dankeschön massive subscription tommy auch wieder
am start dankeschön leute
pack knöpfe drücken so pattern matching switch da steige ich immer aus das kriege
ich immer nicht richtig zusammen command switch ok ok also also ich will switch switch
auf
sensor data
value
switch
ne
bonkers
Ich da bin ich da bin ich der der übelste kack noob drinne
Wie wie funktioniert das noch mal switch
Ne da muss ich doch jetzt sagen, irgendwie, so das hier ist Default, das ist Default wert,
so.
Gut, ok, also, ähm, Sensor Data, so rum.
Oh man, wie ging das jetzt nochmal so, ne, jetzt kann ich so machen, genau, genau, aja,
alles klar.
Key soll sein Unit und Value soll sein Kilometer, so geht das, genau, dann soll die Unit Kilometer
sein.
jetzt habe ich es jetzt habe ich so wenn unit dafür ist nämlich diese pattern
matching geschicht tatsächlich ganz praktisch dann wenn unit meils dann soll
es me sein sie richtig sehr ja so und ansonsten soll es leer sein
dann kriege ich hier unit
Ich schreibe einfach, dass man es übergeben muss.
Sehr schön.
Okay, mal gucken, ob das jetzt klappt.
Mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Also, wenn das funktioniert, dann sollte jetzt im Home Assistant angezeigt werden,
dass das hier zum Beispiel jetzt Unit Miles hat.
Da sollte dann Miles dahinter stehen.
Sollen die anderen Units nicht auch gleich übergeben?
Ich weiß nicht was die anderen units sind. Das ist doch das ding
Zum Beispiel ihr battery state of charge das liefert keine units mit
Man kann sich denken dass es prozent ist ja aber dann müsste ich dann quasi jedes feld
Manuell mappen auf einen auf eine unit und wenn vier das fällt morgen umbenennt dann kackt meine ganze
integration ab
meine ganze add-on ab
Oder funktioniert nicht mehr richtig abkacken wird es nicht aber klappt der wert nicht
Aber da wo ich es habe
Ja du hast recht das könnte man das könnte man tatsächlich machen ja
Wobei man da auch wieder der druck der sehr witzig der druck da steht ja gar nicht drinne wir gucken gleich mal wir gucken
gleich mal wo wir überhaupt units haben lassen wir mal kurz schauen wir haben es doch hier wo
haben wir hier unit also unit kilometer kilometer unit 0 super fuel amount beim elektroauto keckel
kpa was ist das kilo paskal oder was ist das kilo pasca kann man eh vergessen der pressure
Pressure liest er eh nicht aus.
Volts, ja gut, das könnte man tatsächlich setzen, Kilometer.
KMPL.
Was?
Was ist KMPL?
Kilometer?
Pro?
Länge?
Nee.
K-L-L.
liter es ergibt beim elektroauto keinen sinn aber gut die api ist ja vielleicht
auch für andere sachen als elektroautos ja kilometer per pro liter das
unterstützt homos ist es nicht mal
es gibt sind durchsinniger weise es gibt es eigentlich wirklich nur kilometer
und Volt, wo man das machen könnte. Leute, eigentlich ist die Konvertierung sogar hier
besser. Guck mal, hier habe ich die Werte doch. Warum mache ich die Konvertierung nicht
hier? Scheiß doch hier oben drauf, keck. Scheiß doch hier oben drauf. Ich kann auch
die Konvertierung einfach hier machen. Ach ne, kann ich nicht. Das ist ja nur erst nach
der konvertierung so null wobei doch kann ich kann ich kann die konvertierung einfach hier machen
schauen wir mal aber wir probieren es erstmal so aus mit unit so also wenn das jetzt funktioniert
wenn ich das richtig gemacht habe hier mit mit home assistant export dann sollte der jetzt anzeigen
dort wo
Da sollte als miles und so dahinter stehen gleich macht es nicht okay
exportiere ich das irgendwie falsch?
unit unit of measurement
das sieht doch jason technisch erst mal richtig aus oder net
unit of measurement gucken wir mal was der überträgt was der mqtt technisch überträgt zeigt mal her
Was?
Bild failed?
Hä?
Was will er von mir?
Läuft das vielleicht noch irgendwo im Hintergrund?
Hängt das irgendwie?
Ohja, guck mal das hängt.
Null Kill.
Das da weg.
Ohja.
Was will er von mir?
Läuft das vielleicht noch irgendwo im Hintergrund?
Hängt das irgendwie?
Oh ja, guck mal das hängt.
Null Kill.
Das da, weg.
Weg damit.
Ich hoffe ich habe jetzt nicht zu viel abgeschossen.
hast eine leer zeile zwischen
punkt und unit
Sollte eigentlich egal sein aber ja du hast recht wir machen das mal weg
Run
So jetzt müssen wir gleich was sehen was er überträgt und da sollte jetzt irgendwas mal kurz noch ein bisschen enter, enter pushen dass ich
gleich sehe da müsste jetzt ja eigentlich die unit mit drin stehen klein so alter
please mehr übertragen okay sieht irgendwo einer was mit unit
Geh mal kurz rauf, so, müsste relativ am Anfang sein.
Unit of Measurement, tja das ist leer, ich suche jetzt wo das drinnen steht.
Units of Measurement
0?
Was?
Miles?
Oh Gott, was ist das für Ausgaben?
Distance to Empty, Distance, da müsste doch eigentlich was drinnen stehen, oder?
Ja, dass es leer ist, ist okay, aber es sollte zumindest mal irgendwo...
Wie heißt denn das hier, nach was ich gucken muss? Moment. Wie heißt denn das? Zum Beispiel Distance to Service.
Distance to Service. Wie sucht man da drin was? So.
So.
Alter, wie sucht man den Team?
Kommt scheiß drauf.
So.
Kekl.log.
Beste.
Ja, es steht in jedem Block, aber es sollte bei manchen was drinstehen.
Oh mann, sag mal, warum verreckten jetzt mein Bild immer?
Was ist denn das?
Wollen die mich rollen?
Das hängt einfach jetzt, ist das irgendein.net Bug oder so?
Was ist denn da los?
Warum hängt denn das?
So, der sollte jetzt gleich was reinschreiben.
Re-Write in Go, in Go wird nicht mehr re-Writed, wenn schon re-Written in Rust, Placingly Fast.
Go, mit Go gebe ich mir nicht, gebe ich mich nicht mehr ab.
Wenn schon bin ich, mache ich das wie die coolen Leute und, und, und Reiter alles in
Rust.
So, Distance to Service. Unit of Measurement ist leer. Warum? Warum ist Unit of Measurement
leer? Distance to Service? Ah. Wait a minute. Warum ist das leer? Ähm.
Warum ist das, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
SensorData Ah ja natürlich, funktioniert ja auch so
nicht wie ich das hier mache.
In Sensor Data Key steht ja der komplette Key drinnen und Value Kilometer ist schon
ok, aber Key stimmt ja nicht, Key ist ja nicht, Key ist ja nicht richtig.
Kann ich, kann ich jetzt da drinnen irgendwie sowas machen und und?
Ne ne das funktioniert gar nicht, ja, ja das ist natürlich, das ist natürlich doof.
ich will ich muss ja gucken ob es ob es mit mit kilometer endet
irgendjemand planen wie man das im pattern matching macht wenn wenn es wenn es endet mit
mit end, end, ah, aber wie krieg ich denn jetzt den value, wie krieg ich jetzt hier
den value ich muss jetzt gucken
Ich weiß mal ich muss ich muss sagen sie ist
Ist?
Nee.
Geht das so?
Ach du Scheiße man!
ja ich weiß dass das nicht geht wie kann ich wie kann ich denn jetzt überhaupt überprüfen
ob das ich will type check machen ok c sharp pattern switch type check also eigentlich
ich will nicht wirklich type check machen ich will zugriff auf den auf den werte haben
so wir gucken mal wir gucken mal ein bisschen was hier
Not Null geht das?
Ne
Wie kann ich denn, wie kann ich denn entscheiden?
Not Null geht das?
Ah ne okay das funktioniert so nicht
Da bin ich zu zu pp ich glaube glaubt das funktioniert so nicht
Ich meine ich kann auch mal ich kann einfach normale ifs machen wenn ich irgendwie
WTF
Also jetzt jetzt wird es mir zu advanced hier guckt euch das mal an
Multi Inputs
Ne, mein Problem ist, ich will das, ich will das konvertieren.
Kann man da nicht noch einen zweiten Check irgendwie dabei machen?
Ne das bezieht sich immer alles da drauf, also ich kann jetzt nicht einfach ein to string
oder so da drin machen.
Ok da muss ich mich noch ein bisschen mehr mit beschäftigen.
Also mein Problem ist ja, dass ich nicht checken will ob Key Unit ist, sondern ich will gucken
ob Key mit Unit endet.
Also ich will quasi hier, was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen, ah ja gut er weiß, dass das
und jetzt hier ends, ends with, aber das ergibt ja keinen Sinn, oh, regex, ne ne ne
Okay, okay, okay das, wie gesagt, mit dem IF würde es total einfach funktionieren.
Also was man machen kann ist natürlich so was hier, guck, var unit gleich plupp
Da machst du ein IF, guckste, guckste IF, ähm, sensor data key gleich gleich ne nicht
gleich gleich key ends with unit und und sensor data value gleich gleich kilometer easy das
wäre ganz einfach dann sagst du unit gleich kilometer das ganze machst du aber das ich
dachte das geht irgendwie über pattern matching viel nicer
Kannst du dem nach dem geschweiften klammern in namen geben das eine gute idee aber ich glaube
nicht oder doch ja das habe ich doch das habe ich gesucht easy genau das meine ich ja genau
Genau so habe ich das gemeint, das habe ich die ganze, oh ne, genau, ja, genau, value,
Kilometer so dann suchen wir hier nach Key Value Pair und dann gucken wir weiter
Kann ich da jetzt nicht drauf zugreifen?
Okay, nee.
Kann ich?
Muss ich das hier drinnen machen?
Ahja, hier funktioniert das jetzt, okay.
Okay, das ist wirklich Highly Advanced Pattern Matching Kram hier schon.
So, und jetzt kann ich ja Ki welche.
E?
Ends with?
Ja, aber das ist natürlich jetzt auch doof weil
Da müsste ja quasi jetzt irgendwie den if draus bauen oder so
Boah man
Monkeis keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
Also wenn das mit Unit endet, dann wenn das Unit hat und Value Kilometer, dann Kilometer,
ansonsten Miles.
else if unit oder miles so und ansonsten den else brauchen wir nicht den else ist ja schon
der standard fall es ist unit so das sollte jetzt funktionieren alter was sag mal
oh tommy jetzt wirds advanced das probieren wir jetzt noch mal kurz aus whoops
So was meinst du also
Pfeil achso ja das würde funktionieren aber das ist doch eklig du hast schon recht also
das würde das würde funktionieren denke ich mal ja das das würde
wahrscheinlich funktionieren aber das ist ja wirklich eklig kann man sich das
ja das ganze pattern gematch eigentlich auch fast schon sparen das ist ja das
Das ist ja doof.
Das geht bestimmt schöner.
Ach du Scheiße, was ist jetzt passiert?
Okay jetzt ist gar nichts mehr lesbar.
Ich brauche wenn
Wenn ah
Ah ja ja ja das ist gut ja so sieht das das ist
Das will ich haben genau
Das ist gut, was passieren soll ist folgendes, das hier soll als Kilometer oder Meilen angezeigt
werden ordentlich.
Das ist natürlich jetzt schon besser.
So, jetzt machen wir das ganze nochmal, nur dass das Value Miles sein soll und dann hier
ME.
Und ansonsten ist es standardmäßig das, viel besser als so, easy, easy.
So, das sollte jetzt funktionieren. Schön ist es vielleicht nett, aber funktioniert.
Warum hängt sich mein Bild jetzt auf? Was hat er? Warum hängt das jetzt immer?
Was ist denn das für ein Müll? Kill. Was mache ich denn hier? Ich kille immer die
den Dinger. Kill. Was? No? Note Mode 8. Ich gehe mal einen Plan, warum das jetzt sich
neuerdings aufhängt, anstatt sich ordentlich zu beenden und er irgendwie endlos schleift
vor sich hin
naja gut
kann man sowas? ich glaub das checkt das nicht gell
psauksgrab.netgrabnotmode
Kann, kann P-Kill?
Kann das, kann das irgendwie...
Regex, oder so?
Pattern.
Ach, welche, welche Pattern kann man da angeben, schön.
Ein Pattern ist jetzt, äh, äh, ach, bisschen, bisschen schwierig.
Kann man sowas hier sagen?
was?
ah ihh ne läuft immer noch
ok
dann, dann, dann, dann
machen wir das so
so kill, ne PS aus
crep ne so und jetzt
ehm ok
AWK man jetzt wirds
abartig AWK
abartig
ok
A, W, K, R, I, N, Z, Zwei, Kill, Sixhead, Alter, Moment mal, die ID ändert sich doch
immer.
Aus irgendwelchen gründen hängt das neuerdings nach dem ausführen.
Ich glaube es ist jetzt p-crep ist oder crep macht jetzt, aber jetzt sollte es zumindest
danach sich wieder abschießen automatisch.
Ich weiß nicht warum das hängt ehrlich gesagt.
So gucken wir mal ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Ich habe es natürlich nicht mit, jetzt kriege ich es nicht mit, aber, Unit of Measurement.
Aha!
Miles, Moment, jetzt hängt er an, Miles, Miles dran, wait a minute, to bait it.
Ne das funktioniert ja auch gar das funktioniert ja überhaupt nicht so
Ach du kacke
Ich muss ja, boah ist das eklig alter. Ich muss ja rausfinden ob das
Parent beziehungsweise
Das ist ja ein anderer Key
Das ist ja ein anderer Key, guck mal, das ist ja, oh das ist eklig, alter.
Hier steht ja drin Unit Kilometer und parallel dazu gibt es den Value, der braucht eigentlich
die Unit Kilometer.
Mit dem if Statement hätte genauso wenig funktioniert.
Das Problem ist nicht, dass hier was nicht funktioniert, das funktioniert richtig, das
macht auch genau das gleiche wie das if Statement, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass ich den falschen
Knie nehme, da fällt mir jetzt nichts Gescheites zu ein, weil das hier ist in einer Schleife
und ist das auch noch in einer For Each, also in der Parallel For Each, ich müsste jetzt
eigentlich gucken, ob es zu diesem Value parallel was gibt, wo eine Unit mit Kilometern drin
ist.
Ne, das ist voll für'n Arsch, das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz, ich muss mal kurz die ganzen, ich muss mal kurz den Kram
hier ausgeben.
Sensor Data, Sensor Data Key und Sensor Data Value, dann machen wir irgendwie mal so ein
ein bisschen Begrenzung drunter und führen das nochmal aus, aber jetzt hängt es wenigstens
nicht.
Ich glaube nämlich das funktioniert gar nicht so ohne weiteres, da muss man sich noch mehr
überlegen, weil das gar nicht alle Informationen in diesem Schleifendurchlauf hat, was man
braucht bzw. was man ändern will.
Guck genau, genau, hier sieht man es nämlich, schaut mal, guck mal da.
Hier, das ist der Key mit der Unit und ein anderer Key ist das wo eigentlich der Wert
drinne steht, ja das kann ja so überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Ich wüsste dann quasi, dass vorher irgendwie sp- MonkaS, mann, oh Gott, Scheiße man, wie
macht man das jetzt?
Okay, mir fällt eine äußerst ekliche Lösung ein, pass mal auf, das wird jetzt richtig
abartig also und wieso nimmst du nicht daraus die unit direkt weil ich die nicht die unit
auf diesem element setzen muss sondern auf einem anderen guck mal hier steht die unit
drin weil aber gesetzt werden muss die eigentlich hier unten drunter für also mir fällt mir
mir fällt was ganz abartiges ein was wir machen könnten, passt mal auf, jetzt kommt
es, jetzt kommt es, also wir setzen hier nicht einfach miles value, sondern wir setzen hier
an der stelle, keck, leerzeichen miles, ups, wenn ich das jetzt noch richtig schreiben
würde. Oh, Leerzeichen Miles. Passt mal auf. Sensor Data. Da müssen wir allerdings gucken,
das ist jetzt wirds eklig also wenn also der key sollte auf jeden fall mit value enden
jetzt weil wir den da, den da nehmen und wenn
ach du großgeil und wenn der, ich muss jetzt, ich mach jetzt, gut dafür das kriegen wir
glaube ich Pattern Matching jetzt wirklich nicht hin, also ich weiß doch noch gar nicht
so genau was ich machen will. Also sensor data key, der muss auf jeden fall mit value
enden in dem fall jetzt, weil jetzt wollen wir da drauf zugreifen. Wenn der mit value
endet und das value endet auch auch mit miles das ist absolut nicht fehleranfällig oder
so ja die videos teilschrift für den sub so wenn das auch auf miles endet dann und
jetzt wirds richtig abartig, dann, replacen wir hier drin wieder, miles mit nix. Moment,
warum geht das jetzt an der Stelle nicht? Ach weil man das hier nicht mehr setzen kann,
ach mann was ist das lull aber ich muss es ja gar nicht replace ich muss ich muss ja nicht
replace ich bin mir da auch nicht sicher also auf jeden fall auf jeden fall unit brauchen wir
auf jeden fall so unit ist in dem fall gleich miles und das value brauchen wir nämlich auch
noch dass das value ist erst mal erst mal gar nichts das welt das value ist
set sensor data value ok ansonsten ist es aber replace miles dadurch ok ok
Nice top top, so braucht man das, so muss das sein
Value? Value brauchen wir jetzt den da
Warum bereitest du dir vorher die Daten nicht als Objekt auf? Nee ist es doch, ist es doch, außer halt die Details
Weil das halt so von der API kommt
und sich das ändern kann also da können durchaus morgen mal zwei neue Felder reinkommen und manche
Felder draus verschwinden und so kein bock dass das kaputt geht letztendlich wird es mir an der
Stelle jetzt aber auch nicht viel bringen so miles ach du scheiße wenn das funktioniert
dass da müssen wir uns erst müssen wir erstmal hände wäschen so also wenn das value sondern
dann machen wir das nächste
else if
wenn sensor da
das enthält kilometer
dann ist unit kilometer
ne da steht ja dann gar nichts drinne
boah fuck
alter
WTF
ok ich will jetzt einfach mal gucken ob es prinzipiell
das IPL funktioniert.
Sehmlicher.
Oh, oh, oh, Leute.
Oh, Miles.
Massive.
Moment, das funktioniert ja nicht. Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Es hat nicht funktioniert Leute, es hat nicht funktioniert. Hat nicht, hat nicht funktioniert. Nope. Sieht nur so aus, hat nicht funktioniert. Hat nicht funktioniert.
Es hat nicht, hat nicht funktioniert.
Hat nicht, hat nicht, hat nicht geklappt.
Etwas funktioniert. Mensch, okay das ist aber nicht so, das kann man nicht machen.
Ich blicke ich blicke ich blicke ich blicke selbst nicht mehr durch gerade da draußen regnet es jetzt voll was da los
Ne ne das ist das ist kacke das kann man so nicht machen
Aber warum das hier nicht greift, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Also zumindest... was hat er denn hier?
ja miles endet mit value ist doch richtig endet mit value und endet mit miles
hätte es gedacht dass das würde funktionieren
ach es ist ja auch nicht unit miles es ist unit me ich kacke noob
doch jetzt wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren
So, schauen wir mal, so das sollte jetzt hier auf miles auf mi springen, klar.
Ah, guckt mal, easy, funktioniert.
Und wie kann man jetzt nachgucken, ob das richtig ist, da muss ich wahrscheinlich jetzt
irgendwie in developer tools gucken ob er das jetzt richtig gecheckt hat
unit of measurements me was passiert denn da wenn ich unit of measurements
measurements in den blödsinn reinschreibe so keckel zum beispiel weil wenn es einfach nur
ein wert ist der dann irgendwo da steht dann kann man sich das im prinzip auch sparen
Gleich gucken ob jetzt Unit of Measurements Kackel ist.
Geil!
Also, ne das bringt es jetzt ja nicht so wirklich.
Kann man nicht die Kilometer von der Datenliste nehmen und dann eine reinzufügen, die die
dann umrechnen.
Doch, du kannst ein Value-Template oder ein Template-Sensor machen, das funktioniert.
Du kannst dir in Home Assistant quasi einen Sensor anlegen, das geht sogar glaube ich
mittlerweile über das Web-Interface, der immer gesetzt wird, wenn es aktualisiert wird
und dann umrechnen doch doch das kannst du mal also das könnte der typ theoretisch auch selbst machen im webinterfer also in in in seinem
home assistant ja das müsste ich eigentlich gar nicht einbauen also also rein von geht es oder geht es nicht
Und was bringt mir das jetzt dass ich unit of measurements gesetzt habe im home assistant das verstehe ich noch nicht so genau
Was was bringt das jetzt unit?
Also was ist der Sinn davon überhaupt?
Moment, wenn ich das jetzt rechne, der das jetzt um, wenn ich das jetzt in miles habe?
aber das probieren wir jetzt mal aus das das das probieren wir jetzt mal ob das jetzt vom
user irgendwie abhängt lull dass das wäre es jetzt ja also m e miles ja feet inches inches
das müssen wir gleich nochmal. Also sprich, jetzt habe ich das hier, so k distance to empty,
so machen wir mal jetzt hier eben in der Übersicht, in Anzeige Entity, Anzeige wunderbar, k, value,
Okay, Miles. Und wenn ich das jetzt umstelle, mein Profil auf Deutsch, rechnet er das dann
in Kilometer um? Das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass der so schlau ist. Language?
German? Nee, Deutsch. Okay, Zahlenformat? Ach nee, Moment.
die zeit wird er vielleicht umrechnet aber nicht nicht kilometer und so was oder gibt
sie jetzt längen das ist dem vollkommen egal der rechnet es nicht um home assistant miles
zu kilometer die machen das bestimmt die machen das bestimmt mit mit template sensor ja ja ja das
dachte ich mir die man das mit dem template sensor das ist easy template sensor ist kein
ding aber du musst auf jeden fall was machen der macht das nicht komplett automatisch
device tracker mom velocity wo wir wissen wie schnell seine mutter ist welcher velocity
die sich gerade bewegt also das geht ja aber das mit dem umrechnen hier muss wenn
die das nämlich alles mit irgendwelchen template sensors machen dann bringt das
nichts moin kai gaming ne da muss ich da muss ich das selbst umrechnen da muss ich
das selbst umrechnen ok also es funktioniert im prinzip so wie gedacht aber es ist wahnsinnig
ekelig so will ich das nicht lassen also das umrechnen in meilen und so ist
tatsächlich gar nicht so schwierig das ist zwar vielleicht so nicht schön aber
ja aber das hier unten ist tatsächlich äußerst abartig
Könnte das mit irgendeinem Value Template machen in Hormosis, dass man ihm sagt woher
er das bekommt, aber ich weiß nicht, ich glaube da verzichten wir erstmal drauf.
Bei der Gelegenheit. Habt ihr eine gute Idee für einen... Moment.
Integrationen MQTT-Devices. Kackeldev. Guck mal, die haben ja alle diesen Standard-Sensor-Icon.
Sollen wir Längeneinheiten vielleicht irgendwie in extra Icon verpassen?
Es wird abgefragt, ob man Kilometer oder MI haben will.
Ok?
ausgewählt hier und nicht miles warum sollte ich miles ausgewählt haben system
Amsterdam perfekt
Aber in diesem in diesem setup ist das doch normalerweise oder hier. Nee man wird eigentlich hier hier wird man gefragt
Also das können die anscheinend noch nicht intern umrechnen, aber deswegen ist wenn das
in Zukunft kommen sollte, ist es tatsächlich nicht verkehrt das mit der richtigen Einheit
zu versehen.
Ja
Na gut, machen wir das mal aus. Also prinzipiell funktioniert das. Wir müssen das jetzt allerdings noch ein bisschen schöner machen. Ich meine das ist
doch wirklich abartig. Das können wir das können wir so nicht lassen.
Ok erstmal müssen wir das hier oben ein bisschen schicker machen, weil da blicke ich schon gar
nicht mehr durch was das überhaupt sein soll.
Wir extrahieren das mal, also zumindest machen wir das an der Stelle schon mal nicht.
extra hin eine Methode draus und die heißt jetzt was ja wunderbar die heißt jetzt was
ich konvert kilometer oder machen wir konvert values from möglichst lang 2 miles das könnte
fast schon das könnte fast schon java sein so convert so das müssen wir jetzt noch checken
ob wir ab config miles habe ich noch gar nicht drinne das brauchen wir nämlich auch
noch dass wir das überhaupt als settings einstellen können weil die meisten wollen
ja Kilometer haben. Die meisten wollen ja Kilometer haben. Also irgendwie, ähm, Convert
miles, ne, Convert Kilometer to miles. Standardmäßig false. Convert Kilometer to miles, wenn man
das noch richtig schreiben würde. Dann wollen wir das da machen. Wo ist das hier? Was macht
das da? Geh weg. Kommt da unten hin. Kommt da hin. So. Convert values for miles. So
jetzt lasst mal kurz überlegen, wie machen wir das jetzt ein bisschen schöner. Weil
das mit dem if also die schleife mit dem if in dem if das das das gefällt mir
irgendwie nicht also dann wir filtern wir filtern das
erstmal also war blub mir fällt auch keine gute variabler ein also wechikel details
so und dann alle descendants die auf type j property sind ist nämlich glaube ich
viel besser an der stelle also sprich das ist das was wir hier machen die
oft halb property sind wir wir und jetzt machen wir diesen diesen check also
Quasi das da
Ne
Wie mache ich das jetzt da drin richtig
Ach ist
Blit schon verwendet ne so und soll es haben wir das wo es aufhört mit unit
Und als letztes war noch eine abfrage wo
value to string gleich kilometer ist da können wir uns nämlich dieses ganze ding hier sparen
guck mal wir können das quasi auch wenn es blub ein ziemlich dummer name ist wir können
das ganze ding hier ersetzen das brauchen wir nicht mehr
das brauchen wir nicht mehr, so und hier unten, so könnte man das jetzt machen,
Es wird dann zumindest schon ein bisschen, ein bisschen klarer aussehen, was jetzt hier
eigentlich passiert.
Weil das heißt Plup, Plup ist vielleicht nicht der sprechenste Name, man könnte es,
man könnte es J-Properties oder so nennen.
So, das ist doch jetzt schon mal ein bisschen besser lesbar, was da passiert.
Der sucht sich alle Elemente raus, die vom Typ J-Property sind, guckt ob es Unit im Key hat, also ob die Dinger Unit heißen und ob das Value Kilometer ist.
Das erkennt man doch jetzt ganz gut.
Dann konvertiert er den ganzen Kram in ein Double, Double nimmt er dann mal 0,62 um das in Meilen umzurechnen.
Und ja, dieses ekliche Zeug hier brauchen wir eigentlich nicht mehr, das machen wir mal lieber weg.
So das muss jetzt funktionieren und ich schon mal eine ganze ecke besser lesbar als der krempel vorher
Mal schauen das jetzt klappt wie gesagt fliet fliet sehe ich aktuell nicht den grund zu warum ich das verwenden sollte
hast du schon ausprobiert
Also ich sehe wirklich den Vorteil nicht für mich, mein.NET Zeug mache ich in Rider und
in der passenden anderen IDE ganz kleine Edits und schnelle Sachen mache ich mit Wim auf
Kommandozeile und ich weiß halt nicht, wozu ich es brauchen sollte.
Also der Vorteil von Wim auf der Kommandozeile ist, es ist halt instant da, instant editiert
Instant wieder weg. So, VS Code braucht halt 2-3 Sekunden, bis es auf ist. Fleet braucht
wahrscheinlich 20 Sekunden, bis alles geladen ist, so wie Ryder. Ich weiß nicht, wo eben
keine Ahnung, wo da genau das Sinn drin ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh Leute, es hat nicht funktioniert. Kekl, guck mal. Steht da wieder Kilometer drin.
Convert values from miles to Kilometer. Warum hat es jetzt wieder nicht funktioniert? Ah,
ich weiß warum das nicht funktioniert hat, weil ich auch dumm bin, guck mal, ich hab
die option gar nicht gesetzt, da muss drinnen stehen, hier option, convert miles, convert
kilometer to miles, ansonsten macht er das nicht, was ja auch richtig so ist, soll es
ja auch gar nicht machen, wenn es einer nicht ausgewählt hat, aber jetzt kann man es wieder
viel besser lesen.
Fleet braucht dreimal an RAM.
Als was?
Fleet Memory Usage is interesting.
Zeig mal her.
Boah.
Da kann ich aber noch ein paar Browser-Taps für aufmachen, oder?
Ich mein, Wurzel Studio Code braucht auch ordentlich.
hatte das auch noch im vergleich ja nee krasse
also ich verstehe den sinn nicht warum ich verhalten sollte
Guck mal hier, VS Code 600MB und man muss mal ehrlich sagen, für einen poplichen Texteditor,
so standardmäßig ist 600MB RAM schon normal, wobei, wenn du das Studio Code wirst, kannst
du ja mit Addons krass aufmotzen, aber sag mal so, für einen Texteditor oder generell
für ein Fenster in dem ich Text editieren kann.
Sind 600 MB RAM schon richtig heftig?
Jetzt hier irgendwie von 4 GB RAM oder von 3,5 GB RAM reden wir mal gar nicht.
Ich mein in der heutigen Zeit hast du zwar RAM as fuck, aber man muss doch nicht für
Fenstern zum Text editieren 3,5 Gigabyte raushauen oder?
Ja ich habe auch 32G, die ich eigentlich normalerweise nicht brauche, aber es ist schon heftig guck
mal.
Guck mal hier 27,4 endlich bei ordentlich Auslastung.
Massive RAM Usage
Leerer RAM ist verschwendeter RAM
Ja so siehts aus, ist so
So ist es, es kann man nicht anders sagen.
Mir fehlt ehrlich gesagt gerade die zündende Idee, wie ich den Sensor setzen soll auf Miles.
Außer über diesen eklichen Hack, den ich vorhin gemacht habe.
Hm...
Tü tü tü... Tü tü tü... Tü tü tü...
Wir könnten...
Lasst mal überlegen.
Mein Vorteil hiervon ist, dass es parallel ist.
Ich kann jetzt nicht, dadurch dass es parallel ist, bringt es nichts, wenn ich jetzt hiervon
auf einen anderen Wert ziehe.
Das muss ich vorher machen.
So, wie kann ich das jetzt gescheit hinkriegen?
Hier ändere ich alle Werte von Kilometer auf Miles.
ich müsste das eigentlich zusammenfassen an der stelle leute ich glaube ich glaube ich müsste folgendes machen dass das funktioniert
das ist so ein bisschen das was der chat auch vorhin geschrieben hat und wie wir ja alle wissen chat
Kennt sich aus
Cute ist chat wieder
Chat ist nicht nur cute chat ist auch noch absolut high IQ
Man könnte das ja hier zusammenfassen
man könnte ja sagen dass man noch ein zusätzlichen noch ein zusätzliches
element anlegt du checkst nicht was hier abgeht ja also bist ich freue mich trotzdem dass du da
Schön, dass du hergefunden hast.
Wenn du was wissen willst,
frag einfach. Aber ich vermute mal,
dass das hier gerade für dich eher so wie in der Schule ist.
Und nach dem Motto, Lehrer schwätzt dich
zwei Stunden zu, du hast nichts gecheckt.
Und dann sagt der Lehrer so, ja,
ähm, also wer
noch Fragen hat, jetzt fragt mal.
Und dann gibt's dann die Leute so, ja, ich hab
nix verstanden. Ja, was genau?
Alles.
Wenn dann der Lehrer sagt,
ich muss schon mal genau und muss schon jetzt genauer
nachfragen aber ich habe doch gar nichts verstanden
wenn du mehr ahnung also gut wenn du ahnung von java hast dann kommst du zumindest am sündagsmäßig halbwegs mit
also ich habe eine idee also wisst ihr was man theoretisch machen könnte
ich meine wir haben jetzt hier die werte und alles wir könnten sagen anstatt dass wir
an der stelle
Ja, wo wir moment ist dass das value property jetzt wir können ich ja eigentlich noch was neues einfügen
Falls das funktioniert ich probiere das mal kurz ich probiere das mal man könnte jetzt quasi was neues einfügen so was wie keckel
Ihr kennt muss irgendwas irgendwas sind so weiß ich auch mal das an und anonymen konvertieren kann ob das geht
new
Ach man das machen checken die das ok so und jetzt könnte ich hier nämlich also ein objekt angeben und sache hier drinnen nehme ich unit
und in dem fall
Ja, dann halt miles ja
Müßte ich dann auch machen für kilometer
unit miles
Ne das geht nicht ja
Warum nicht was was das problem cannot convert string unit to ja ok
Ja gut
New j proper property
Name
Ne, nicht property. Value. Value. Moment, ich bin. Ne. J-Object doch sogar, oder?
ist ja was ich bin da gerade zu blöd für das zu schreiben also wir können meine güde
mensch komm hier pass ich schreib das einfach mal als jason da jetzt in line ob das dann
ob das dann funktioniert wir können jetzt neue c sharp feature verwenden weiß ich wer
das noch nicht kennt mit dotnet 7 und c sharp 11 ist es glaube ich kann man endlich so was hier machen
multilines auch die idee zeigt mist an das funktioniert trotzdem
multiline strings mit drei dreimal
zeug hier
ups what the fuck
so ein bisschen pyson style ist das
Also das muss eigentlich kompilieren, ich glaube
Die idee wollte kann sagen die ist einfach nur lahm was das angeht multiline strings kann man jetzt machen hier guckt
Was ziemlich nice das ist jetzt alles eins zu eins taucht das da drin so auf also im prinzip
wir so was haben wie unit, miles, so und dann wollen wir haben value, gleich äh ja hier
miles value. So nachdem es in json objektes wollen wir das eigentlich so haben. So und
Wenn man da drinne jetzt was, was machst du da, Monkeys, gehst fort, so, wie es mich nicht
das vorne ausrichten lassen will, so und nachdem wir jetzt ja da trotzdem Template Strings
verwenden wollen, müssen wir glaube ich jetzt so machen, dass das funktioniert, ja genau,
Das ist mal Six-Hat-Syntax hier, guck mal, also funktioniert folgendermaßen, ich kenne
keine Sprache, die das so cool implementiert hat, wie C-Sharp an der Stelle.
Wenn du hier deine Triple Quotes machst, dann ist das erstmal wie in Python, alles was
da drinnen ist, ist escaped, wenn du allerdings da drinnen jetzt wiederum was einsetzen willst,
du quasi eine beliebige anzahl an dollar zeichen davor machen und geschweifte klammern auf so oft
hintereinander wie dollar zeichen am anfang stehen bedeutet an der stelle wird es kälte
du kannst was einsetzen also sprich wenn in meinem jason objekt irgendwie doppelt klammern drinne
Vorkommen schon dann würde ich einfach sowas hier machen und dann müsste ich da zum eskäpen quasi
triple
triple eckige klammern aufmachen
Also ich kenne keine andere sprache die es ähnlich macht finde ich aber wirklich nice
So führen wir mal aus ob das jetzt funktioniert wir müssen jetzt wir kriegen jetzt irgend ein objekt mit mit keckel drin wenn es wenn es tut was
Ich was ich mir
Da gedacht habe
Oh
Collection was modified ach das mag er nicht oder was
Heute ist es aber alles gegen uns oder
gut gedacht, aber funktioniert nicht. Collection was modified. RIP F.
Ok, wenn Collection nicht Modified werden darf, dann weiß ich auch nicht, dann fällt
Ich hab jetzt grad nix geschaltet, das ist mir ein, mann.
Okay, okay, doch, doch. Value.
Wartet mal, ich hab ne Idee, ich hab ne, ich hab ne Idee.
Das Modified nämlich die Collection nicht.
So daumendrücken prege leute präge dass das jetzt funktioniert
Weil dann könnte man nämlich doch was ganz cooles machen
Prege, Dankeschön chat wenn das jetzt funktioniert dann haben wir jetzt hier nämlich
Da dürfte jetzt aber nicht einfach nur Miles drinne stehen.
Das ergibt jetzt das ergibt jetzt wenig wenig sinn
Da müsste jetzt da müsste jetzt so eigentlich mein jason objekt drinne sein
Moment moment das muss ich jetzt noch mal checken ob das bild wir löschen das mal kurz die grunde weg die lied
Ja miles weil kokona
Weil man könnte ja Unit und Value quasi in einem speichern und dann kann ich es nachher
auch wieder auslesen.
Ja, der checkt jetzt gar nichts mehr
Distanz
Der sollte da jetzt eigentlich irgendeine JSON Value reinschreiben oder so, macht er
aber nicht.
Moment.
Moment, Moment.
Führt der das überhaupt geradeaus?
Der führt das doch gar nicht aus gerade.
Der führt das doch gar nicht aus.
Warum nicht?
Weil Export Convert Kilometer to Miles.
Warum?
Convert Kilometer to Miles.
Der führte es doch gar nicht aus warum nicht weil export
convert kilometer to miles
Warum wird convert kilometer to miles
Warum warum führt er das nicht aus was ist was ist hier los
Convert values vom kilometer tun
Ist es denn gesetzt
Convert Kilometer to miles true.
Crash das da vielleicht?
Crash das irgendwie und ich krieg nix davon mit?
Komisch.
sehr sehr komisch
Moin kataläer 1453
Das ist sehr merkwürdig oder warum funktioniert das nicht
Leute jetzt blicke ich nicht mehr durch
Ich glaube ich glaube bin ich bin zu lange und schon
Jetzt verstehe ich mein eigentlicher kram nicht mein eigener kram nicht mehr
Funktioniert der Krempel nicht, den ich hier gebaut habe?
Leute zu P-P-Pegahirn, wo ist der Backseating-Chat, wenn man ihn braucht?
Ey, das müsste doch eigentlich stimmen, was ich hier gebaut hab.
Vielleicht, vielleicht will er lieber, dass er einen Pfeil da unten reinmacht.
Hä, was hab ich denn hier gebaut? Macht der überhaupt hier was?
Nö.
ne was zum ach doch aber der konvertiert nix warum moment ich weiß warum alter ich bin
so blöd. Passt mal auf. Ich hab das hier umgestellt auf Lock Level Debug, aber... glaube
Ich habe die back gar nicht gesetzt
Ja jetzt geht's
Da geil also hat es die ganze zeit schon gemacht nur die ausgabe hat nicht funktioniert layer 8 ja
Und jetzt, guck mal, eins, zwei, drei, und jetzt passts ja auch.
Aber trotzdem, warum geht das nicht?
Warum geht das hier nicht?
Was hat der für Schmerzen?
Ich mein, das muss er müssen.
Warte mal, ich mach nochmal aus, sollen wir hier printen.
Alter, was ist mit der Musik los?
Also das wäre doch eine schöne Variante.
Der würde einfach das value hier umschreiben und zwar in eins was unit und value enthält und alles wäre gut
Rightline debugging, ja der brauche debugger keck
overrated, gebated, outdated
Okay, aus irgendwelchen gründen möchte er das aber nicht pushen, okay, okay
Vielleicht wegen dem Leerzeichen hinten dran?
Ich trau denen ja alles zu, oder nimmt er standardmäßig was, was in Value drinne steht?
Nee, Unit of Measurements ist nicht meils.
ha ha sensor value template
ich muss mal kurz noch mal jetzt mqtt mit lauschen was da kommt
ist schon vorbei also normalerweise würde ich erwarten dass jetzt irgendein jason objekt
drinne steht und nicht 1 2 3 4 5 6 ich setze es doch hier ganz offensichtlich oder darf
das standardmäßig einfach nicht value heißen könnte das sein dass es einfach nicht value
heißen darf, sondern Null, die Musik ist bei ein wenig aufdringlich.
Boah noch So ne das juckt den einfach nicht, was pusht
der denn hier? Moment, nee an der Stelle. Der pusht eindeutig das hier als Wert, aber
das interessiert ihn mal gar nicht. Das ist ihm vollkommen egal. Das interessiert ihn
gar nicht ok nice also das das funktioniert nicht wie ich mir das gedacht hab also von
der Idee her wollte ich das jetzt folgendermaßen machen ich wollte den als value hier nicht
einfach die zahl pushen lassen sondern ein jason objekt mit unit und mit zahl
das wäre dann eigentlich recht easy gewesen aber hat er kein bock
so ich mein wir können einfach mal nur den den naggischen string gachi bass
mal pushen ob das irgendwas bringt hyper gachi so das sollte doch eigentlich funktionieren
Was, was, was ist das, was ist dein Problem?
Sag bloß, das geht jetzt nicht in einer Zeile.
Hab ich eine Klammer zu viel, ah, ich noob, ja, Klammer zu viel, ja Klammer muss weg,
Habt recht, hab ich nicht gesehen.
Ja.
Tududududududududududu.
Ah, Moment.
Das geht jetzt?
Aber wenn er selbst konvertiert geht nicht, oder was?
Ja, so wollte ich das nämlich haben.
Habe das doch alles das doch alles abartig ja so in der richtung wollte ich das jetzt
haben weil jetzt könnte ich das an der anderen stelle auslesen dass es miles sind unit of
Measurement setzen auf miles und hätte noch das hätte noch das value
Ne da muss Jason objects können weil muss ja da
Verstehe jetzt nicht genau aber okie weird champ
Ja genau, genau so, genau so. Ja und da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass das, dass
das geht. J-Object. Pass. Warum hat das, warum sollte das nicht funktionieren?
Das ist halt das war ich nicht check gemeint war doch
Beim konvertieren später muss das muss er das ja eh wieder rückgängig machen dann
Da es läuft ja vm das homos ist zum testen ja guck das läuft da da neben dran
Nö, das interessiert ihn einfach mal gar nicht.
Vor einer Minute, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Also weiteres Ob- Achso, ja, ich weiß warum das nicht funktioniert.
weil das wahrscheinlich wieder die collect weil das in der collection gar nicht rein weil das
gar nicht drinne steht ich kann mir vorstellen der checkt das nicht oder ist er doof meine
gürtel machen das gescheit das funktioniert so auch nicht also im prinzip haben wir es ja nur
nur das anzeigen von dem sensor da fällt mir jetzt grad nix gescheites zu ein ehrlich
gesagt weil ursprünglich hatte ich vorwärts übertragenes als jason objekt dann sagen
wir dem home assistant dass der sich hier für dieses value ding interessieren soll
Gut wäre gewesen
aber anscheinend nicht
Dann Weiß Ich auch nicht
Aber Ich Bin auch schon Zu lange am start Leute Ich Kann Es Ich Kann Jetzt Nicht Mal nachdenken Gescheit
Muss mir das gerade Mal Kurz Puschen was wir hier gemacht haben sonst vergesse ich das Wieder
Was Haben wir Jetzt Eigentlich gemacht
Säck
Ja alles gut
Ok also
Beste beste beste beschreibung überhaupt
Aber das bleibt ja eh nicht so
Dass es nicht verloren geht muss ich mal nachher in ruhe noch mal gedanken drüber machen wie man das gescheit machen wie man das gescheit
machen kann
Wollte eigentlich auch noch testen ob das container bild funktioniert das können wir jetzt gar nicht ausprobieren weil weil mittlerweile sollt es sollt es eigentlich so sein
Wenn ich was pushe auf github
Eigentlich soll das mittlerweile wenn ich was auf github pushe entweder als neuer tag oder hier in einem speziellen branche dann baut er
Quasi das image neu mit neuem tag und allem
mal schauen alles klar leute wir sehen uns ich gehe jetzt auf kann ich kann mir keine
kann immer nachdenken bis zum nächsten mal morgen früh bin ich wieder am start wir sehen
Auf wachend streamen, bis denn, C.U.